three two hello everybody it is June 7th
a beautiful Wednesday off the rails of
course
thank you for being here today's episode
is sponsored by
expressvpn honey and stamps and boy do
we love our sponsors
yes
um
today I have a lot to talk about as you
guys know I was
busy yesterday
you know but there's actually
okay so a Envoy just rolled up to the
front of the building
which is weird do you know who was in
that Envoy it was like 20 Su black SUVs
I I'm not really sure what's going on
out there I sent somebody down to check
it out but um
it's weird there's it's like children
[__] yeah well did you notice that like
one really weird vehicle with like the
big glass
it like there was all the SUVs and then
there was like this one very strange
looking vehicle that I didn't recognize
yeah I didn't see that one huh
well if you guys
um Sam did you did you see anyone back
there is that Sam back there
yes did you see anyone in front
if somebody's she's bringing somebody in
hold on
are you sitting down back there who is
this here let me punch it up real quick
what the hell oh
it's the pope mobile to you uneducated
okay oh okay hold the phone what your
holiness
what what are you doing here hello Pope
why are you here and [__] L.A uh the
Lord sent me here to talk to some
transgressors
oh the Lord sent you here okay that's
correct so you came specifically to see
me well I've tried to hit the big
Sinners first you know oh God
what did I do I I didn't do any sins I
mean in your heart my son you know what
you did
okay let's see I mean uh remember that
girl in Modesto I've never been to
Modesto
hold on I I don't I don't know what he's
talking about Highway 99 you don't
recall that oh come on Pope dude drop in
59. that's not fair to bring that up
nobody's supposed to know about that
you're come on me I thought we had a
confidence
well if you can't take it maybe you
should stay home
Jesus man this Pope is feisty
I thought you were supposed to be like
chill God loves you my son
okay that's good well listen I don't
know why you're here you say I'm one of
the biggest Sinners I don't know what
that I don't know why you say that I
mean you're talking about Modesto and
[__] I don't know what the hell uh sorry
can I say God Damn I don't know I I'm
not Christian I'm not Catholic so I I
don't understand the rules of engaging
with the Pope at all did you have some
intelligent intelligent questions to ask
me are you just gonna Mumble on you came
here what the hell are you talking about
I didn't ask you to come here you came
here in your goddamn Pope mobile
I'm everywhere my son the sooner you
realize that the better
you're everywhere
are you God or the Pope I don't think
you know the difference a human being a
chosen by so how are you everywhere the
title is God's vicar on Earth
God's vicar why are you here Pope just
stop guys well I don't understand what's
going on
do you have any intelligent questions
for me sir
no
I literally don't why is this happening
well maybe we should have a private
meeting Maybe
I don't want to embarrass you anymore
because it's too easy to do
all right well uh
thank you maybe you could come to my
place
they call it Vatican City maybe I heard
of it oh it's right near Rome
it's up the street right up the street
from Rome you past the Trevi Fountain
turn left at the Appian Way and boom
there you are PAL yeah I've never been
to Vatican is that why you're here well
it's actually your visit
yeah I don't think I'm wanted there in
Vatican City we had a I don't know why
there's some great artwork there if
you're interested in that you remember
Mike
Mike Angelo
so you're is this stuff on the ceiling
is this a is this a an official
invitation
it is I I'd be overjoyed to have you
there
okay is this a trap are you is this uh I
feel a little bit skeptical that the
pope who's coming here just talking mad
[__] I heard a rumor about you that you
may have accosted
the Vatican okay first of all no it's
not true Pope okay let's get your facts
straight I will not be defamed by the
Pope
okay because people care about what you
say so let's get the facts straight I've
never been to Vatican City I made a joke
about Vatican City that was harmless the
people took way too far I've never been
there or done anything to Vatican City
so I'd appreciate if you get your facts
straight Pope oh you'll sound a little
hostile there man
you brought what do you want okay I'm
sorry I just wanted to visit me at the
Vatican I'm sorry I shouldn't have said
that I understand I took it too far I'm
in the forgiving business okay
is that all
well as I said can I get a confirmation
from you or maybe you'll agree visit me
at the holy city yeah I mean you're
gonna cover my airfare food's on me
food's on you okay what the crackers the
what are the Jesus crackers I don't know
I'm not baptized is that a problem I'm
Jewish to be totally honest with you
that's right one of my flock Jesus was
Jewish first you know
yeah but he left us so I'm not sure if
how you guys feel about you know we
could get into two thousand years of
History here but this is probably not
the Forum as I said I'd appreciate your
confirmation of visiting me at the holy
city
all right is there anything you might
enjoy yourself
I'll come I'll come is there anything
you want me to do I need to do any blood
Mary's or no that's holy Mary's but
that's Holy Mary talk about as I said
we'll talk about that in private be a
lot better than exposing yourself here
in public well it's yeah okay like you
did in Modesto stop it I've never been
to Modesto Pope I I refute that Holy
shame on you oh like like Pope like
you've never sinned
you know what I mean
like you've never stopped on Route 99. I
got well listen no one's perfect besides
what did you say about Ben Shapiro oh my
God stop it why do you even care about
another what I said about another Jewish
guy well I happen to admire Ben
the pope watches Ben Shapiro okay I can
admire Gentile shame on you
okay I admit what I said about Ben
Shapiro was too far but I don't know why
you have a vested interest in that Pub
don't you have other things to worry
about no it's all mankind
no matter their sins or inadequacies
all right well I'm sorry to Vatican City
I'm sorry to Ben Shapiro I mean I don't
I'm assuming you heard the joke I think
it wasn't that bad it was
self-deprecating you know no I suggest
you take your gluteus maximus
and bring it to Rome okay do you know
what a gluteus maximus is
that it's giving me the Roman Empire
Emperor okay well it's your rear end
yeah and and I it was giving me kind of
I'm just saying if in with the with the
reputation the Catholic church has Pope
with all due respect let's not be
talking about gluteus maximuses
well
I want to
forgive you for what you said about the
NRA what about what about you did all
those kids Pope let's talk about what
you did yeah I made a few jokes how many
kids okay have you have have
what about you Pope
sir how many kids Maybe I'm Wrong maybe
you just go straight to professional
help before you come to me
isn't that your job what the [__] you
seem to have an anger issue well Pope
let's be real I mean have you seen the
reports out of Philadelphia and there
was one that came out of Europe I mean
let's talk about what you're doing Pope
to stop this pandemic of child abuse in
the Catholic church it's Pope Phil thank
you okay Philadelphia is a place to talk
I'd love to talk about in fact it
translates as you know to the City of
Brotherly Love yeah well the brotherly
love going on there's a little different
variety wouldn't you say yeah so are you
concerned and maybe you want a part of
that or I don't understand why you're so
hostile
frustration can be a terrible thing my
son
what do you want to know about the NRA
again it's just a stupid joke it doesn't
seem like a sin to make a joke you get
some new writers
the material seems to be kind of insipid
and you're going to look that up later
I know it's insipid means Pope
well we're seeing you getting along
pretty well here
what was your name again
I thought you knew everything
some things I don't want to know
so what about Route 99 and all that
[__] you're really into that you
want me to give give him your phone
number up there
I can make you a reservation remember
room 69 please don't
Pope have you ever partaken in what I've
heard had described are you did you know
about what happened to those kids your
name Ethan decline is that your name oh
my God
or that just a part of your personality
why is the pope following like culture
wars on YouTube does this seems beneath
you I know all these kids
yeah except if you don't know my name
pope did you know about the kids yes or
no
I know a lot about children they're oh
my God
do you have specific accusations maybe
we should talk about it really is now
the time okay let me pull it up
child abuse in the Catholic have you
been perusing YouTube's terms of service
recently oh my can we cut him off please
I got the pope mobile downstairs you
want to go for a ride no no I
mean you probably like that that's all
oh is that is that fat joke your
Holiness you're gonna have a double
double oh my God this guy has no shame
you are you are literally like the pope
is red pilled what's yeah are you gonna
call my wife ugly it goes right along
with your tiny hands
[Music]
okay I'm sick of this guy oh all right
your Holiness thank you so much well
certainly it's a pleasure being here
with you sinners
uh yeah yeah so that's actually true
I'll see you on Mykonos
or San Francisco or what is Mykonos
isn't that we don't know one of
Epstein's Islands
I think you'd be well known there
have you been to Epstein's Island your
Holiness and we're sorry
Jeffrey Epstein's Island oh gosh I had a
reservation in but he he hung himself
before I could get there okay oh wow all
right I always heard he was wrong
I appreciate your candor enough you
admit it yeah I'm into Candor I used to
date a girl in Canada Betty kander She
was like wait wait aren't you supposed
to be virgin Pope no don't tell anybody
I'm sharing with you so you feel people
are watching this this is going live
this is a live stream
I hope so
I'm almost dead
all right Paul well listen I uh that's
pretty pretty let me put it this way
Pope I
you're white I look right your wife is
quite unattractive
what the [__] dude that surgery just
didn't take oh my God that's horrible
rhinoplasty is not a perfect science
okay beautiful she has a perfect nose
she's never had that and Pope shame on
you I mean what are you doing you're lit
he's literally doing the red pilled [__]
do you watch fresh and Fit I mean
well it makes sense that you're since
you're overweight yeah
okay pulp how heavy are you
seems like you've been kicking back
those Jesus places kick your ass Ethan
I'd like to see you try you old [__]
okay step out I got the Pokemon Bill
there waiting for us pal we're gonna run
you over all right get out dude I'm sick
of this I'm not gonna stand here what
what footwear do you have on
what is let me see your shoes Pope oh
I've got Skechers pal Skechers
you know where they're going where the
sun doesn't shine
all right
maybe you better get a new career here I
don't think it's working out for you no
sensitive you have you have other
Sinners I'm assuming to visit I got lots
of them but you're right at the top of
the list that's why I'm here okay you
can leave now okay so I can exit with
your good with your blessing dismute is
Micah okay with your blessing your
Holiness thank you so much for stopping
I don't know if he knows where he is or
what's going on by the way who's your
tailor
is
okay pleasant seeing you and I will take
my leave now I have many many souls to
save it's been a real pleasure talking
to you I only fell asleep hey Pope hey
Pope can't wait to see the smoke rising
from the Vatican from your shorts from
the Vatican you know what that means I'm
looking forward to that smoke Rising my
friend and it's gonna be soon it's going
to be real soon we're gonna see that
smoke Rising quite hostel he's quite
awesome yes I am oh you better it's best
if you leave your Holiness thank you so
get out of here yeah bye a pleasure
seeing you bye yeah they don't die soon
that invitation is open to the Vatican
anytime okay well hopefully we don't see
any wokes white smoke before then bye
you shot for me didn't you bye don't
forget your depends you [__] your pants
on the way out
all right take it easy what an [__]
he's he's elderly give him a break what
the [__] why would you call it you look
ugly that's just like that was that was
shocking that was not cool at all yeah
wow I'm running on like no sleep and I
don't know what the hell I just
witnessed yeah I didn't know I don't
know either
that was bizarre what a dick though like
first of all I've been losing a lot of
weight and I I just
he doesn't appreciate what I'm going
through to sit here and to ridicule me
and talk about Ben Shapiro I'm sorry
it's just not fair
it's not fair
I he's obviously been eaten from the
omelet of knowledge yeah talking about
Route 69 and all that in order to
comprehend you're gonna have to break
some
comprehend in order to comprehend and to
eat the uh the the omelet of knowledge
you're gonna need to break
those eggshells all right thank you
reach all right well there's the pope uh
wow how old is he he's got to be like
85. he's done that many years left yeah
that's that's what's get that's what's
you know keeping me going I know he's
gonna die he doesn't even have two good
years left so yeah fine
okay well where were we uh well maybe we
should talk about why uh
I'm in a mask and uh a B's in a mask
okay so no one else is here so as you
guys know yesterday the title of the
episode was I'm meeting cavi cabby cab
Rye Rye
and um during that meeting I was in a
tiny room for nine hours with my lawyer
who called me this morning and said he
has covid
lovely so I got a special parting gift
[Laughter]
he included the I asked if I get a if I
get a discount on his hourly rate he
said he'll get back to me
yeah so uh I didn't I didn't test
positive this morning but like I said he
he just tested positive this morning so
I mean what's the chance that I
don't have it I was in a room with him
for nine [__] hours yeah it's not
looking too hot for old Ethan here so uh
we're trying to keep away but um on the
bright side it's caused us to bring back
one of our uh well on the bright side
segments here we have Hassan tomorrow
and a double guess episode on Friday
that we'll probably have to cancel okay
that wasn't the bright side I was trying
to suggest I was trying to suggest this
say what up everybody it's the council
where were you guys when the pope was
roasting me
yo I could have used some backup you
guys are sitting there like the Last
Supper it was my last supper and here
getting roasted and y'all just keeping
quiet where's my [__] backup
[Laughter]
so everyone's working from home eat uh a
b good A B is here good A B who has a
good A B good baby we love AB he brought
in a PowerPoint which I'm very excited
to watch today people have been
obsessing over the office
uh uh analogies parallels yes yeah and a
b took it upon himself to make a very
in-depth PowerPoint I'm assuming the
reason that a b
did this before and took the charges
because he's desperate to prove he's Jim
and in fact you are Ryan and I've seen
people saying that it's not just me well
we'll see what the PowerPoint
yes but it's not an unbiased PowerPoint
I just want to put that out it's
scientific
but yeah same kind of science that uh
Abba and preach it's the science
yeah so unfortunately I can't really say
anything about yesterday I signed to NDA
first thing when we sat down
which I guess is pretty it's what you do
when you mediate
so we all signed to NDA so I can't say
anything about it
but I will say this
Ryan Kavanaugh is a
he's a futuristic thinker he is a
trailblazer he is a creative genius no
I'm just kidding thank you thank you I'm
just kidding I was just trying to make
it sound like yeah yeah
drive angry it's it's
I'll put it this way I'm still being
sued
should stop
but I did get probably covered from that
so very good good day
all in all good day it was actually not
a bad day until well I can't wait until
you can't talk about it because you told
us uh that it was a pretty funny
experience so I'm excited to hear what
happened
yeah there'll hopefully be a point where
I can be more loose about it in the near
future but we'll see we'll see we'll see
I can say this the food was bombed dude
that kitchen is stacked is it at a
courthouse or where they have like a
special mediation offices
where and by the way this office was
like
insanely decked the security was nuts
you had to go through like two security
points and then you get a card that only
goes to the floor you're going
it's pretty wild and then you get into
this office super like uh
uh high-end stuff and in the kitchen
it's all like they got like breakfast
burritos and egg sandwiches they have
every candy what they've got all like
candy they've got those eggshells they
got well no there's no eggshells in it
no eggshells there's a refrigerator
stacked with all beverages super nice
coffee machine so and then they brought
lunch no they came up of all that then
they catered um
Mediterranean they brought kebabs out
and those beef Kebab things and the
chicken and all that and I was I was
having a great day honestly I brought my
switch I was playing Zelda it was
phenomenal hell yeah yeah I want a good
dude somebody sue me
I'll see you although it's funny to be
like yeah no this place was awesome it
did cost like
thousands of dollars to pay the mediator
so
at least I got lunch out of it
but yes he's a Visionary thinker and uh
he's a wonderful guy he is a great guy
and he's a tremendous businessman and
1.3 million dollars no no don't
no no don't no sound bites for the next
few days nothing nothing
guys and no con I can't talk about them
for the next few days for sure that's it
thank you
Drive Angry
is YouTube still crashing
oh yeah I can't people are saying can I
at least know if you met him I can't say
anything about it nada
nada I can't say anything about it you
guys
Richard books is suing Dan apparently
let's go to mediation
let's do lunch yeah good time they did
not have the omelet of knowledge at the
in the kitchen no that's this but they
did have eggs that were quite good
um at any rate so that's that I know
it's disappointing but that's all I can
say about it right now
so
um tomorrow by the way uh Marvel drop is
coming out
this is one really yeah
yeah yeah
what uh what character is that
[Music]
sick
foreign
[Music]
do I have to blur this oh do I have to
blur this no oh no the pope was here
dude dude I have some respect he didn't
do it he didn't do it he was just
teasing
so that's I'm looking forward to that
it's exciting really really great stuff
coming up tomorrow at 10 A.M thank you
thank you
thank you what is D-Day
was it D-Day
today's D-Day
like the day the war ended nope
what's D-Day
yeah
Normandy beaches that's what I said
about the war you said when the war okay
whatever D-Day whatever bro okay what
are you talking about D-Day day D-Day
hey
what are you doing to celebrate D-Day
day
he's nuts I'm uh I'm going down to the
beach later I'm gonna paddle out about
two miles not funny
what good men died on that day we lost
good I know man and that's why I'm
honoring them by recreating
their struggle wow that's honoring them
more than you don't even know what the
[__] they did I know what D-Day is no
you said they won the war you don't even
know
whatever
I've seen Saving Private Ryan I know
what the [__] it is right and remember
how that movie opened I got a four in AP
U.S history I'll [__] tell you that I
thought 40 days
what Dan how to what five well you never
took an AP test I did yes that's
actually pretty good thank you Zach four
is a very very good score especially
without knowing what D-Day is it's
impressive
All Right Toby
[__] Toby ass over here what I'm
sorry baby go ahead
honestly I thought D-Day was when Skynet
went live but that's that's Judgment Day
get those mixed up sometimes yeah yeah
get down
thank you Zach okay so well so what are
you saying you're gonna go paddle out
and then like
pretend like you're being machine gun
storm the beach yeah that's awesome
that's pretty cool actually that's
happening thanks thanks bro
uh here you know what
this dude this sound bite of mine is
going crazy you guys it's it's reaching
levels
it's got the uh uh the you guy
here's a podcast apparently a thousand
likes not that not that good but he did
it he had my he had my name in his mouth
let's go
but guys you know what's epic is that
I'm straight up about we I'll say I
reached out to Jack In The Box in
Celsius
if you guys see any other companies
Brands using that sound talk to Daddy
let Daddy know
because I got bills you know what I mean
I got big bills daddy bills
uh but dude it's got like a hundred
thousand uh videos on it now what's the
number can you check Amy
oh yeah
100.
000.
yeah oh here it is you uh that's not it
five thousand gone looking down my phone
yeah but uh let's take a look here
um all of our trees supposed to call in
is that not happening no he's bailing
I'm the idiot [__] [__] didn't you
reach out to you yes [__] dumb yeah
he reached out it was like I want to
come on the show yes and then I was
talking to this guy and it was all set
up and then this morning he was like
Oliver has to cancel yeah like he can't
he don't have five minutes to call you
asked me
[__] dumbass
what a loser man uh it's at 90k post
that's pretty good yeah
W
okay HW so wait I want to do a
comparison can you check the um
Backyardigans Castaway remix how how
many plays did that get oh we I want to
see who's more viral
Castaways we are Castaways you didn't
see that one Dan oh hey there oh I
remember endlessly we are Cast Away
you're asking if you got more shares
than that no [__] chance well I want
to know
it's not even you're you're gonna
embarrass yourself right we can actually
go to the receipts dude
we are Castaways it's possible they
deleted it and this is a re-upload
because this only says eighty thousand
60 posts that sounds right to me Dan
no shot but you have more shares than
that that thing was there bro that sound
bite is massive everybody's doing it
from Noah back all the way to the you
guy check it out dude massive
celebrities Doja cat Madonna oh they
can't I'm that that can't be it Madonna
yes
I do it with everyone
gift cards
from that taco place would be a gift
card oh Jack in the Box taco uh gift
cards I probably will not but I'll I'll
hear what they are all right I got it
that'd be cool 634k
there we go oh [__] okay backyard again
I'll see you come on 600k 600 630 yep I
warned you
that's a lot more than me
all right oh it's been that's been
around for a while yeah for years and it
was massive
we are Castaways
I'm not even on Tick Tock and I know
that that's how you know it's huge
[Music]
no house no car all right thanks Zach I
don't need all that I need that sad [__]
so yeah uh Oliver failed us one idiot
what a loser [__] dumbass idiot fell
off l
uzer
um idiot let's look at some stuff we'll
do we'll do or think our ads and then
after the ad break we'll go straight to
uh a b okay yeah so here is our boy
um we've checked on him before he gives
really useful life tips to young men
here take a look [__] yeah the Pikachu
is a level five singles so some
quiet
we'll need
okay
how how are you gonna get consent to
kill her
I don't think that works that way
yeah Pikachu and stick their sloppy
fingers to the outlet
with her fingers around yeah
hurry up
and you start asking questions
then the electrician is going to look
through her body
electricity
oh what hold on hold up hold up hold up
want to test audio audio people are
saying they can't hear the audio on the
video why oh that's weird yeah I'm I'm
watching it back I can't hear it hold on
yeah everyone's saying sorry about that
can they hear me yeah yeah they just
can't hear the video uh
uh fantastic content dead air my
favorite
everything's fantastic
what could I be missing Zach
everything's unmuted
Zach is uh on the council was it one of
the sends Maybe
I haven't touched [__] as you guys know
it's just Dan and AV here so we are
sorry
wasn't the no the sense turned up the
bus is open the bus is open it's not the
computer audio son
computer audio computer audio send is
people saying it's just the video let me
try opening a different video
but why that doesn't make sense
I could hear a faintly in the background
just wasn't coming through the house can
you can you guys hear this
can you guys hear this
let me know let me know let us know
type big fart juicy fart diarrhea if you
can
keep playing something on that just to
make sure
[Music]
it's very low yeah okay so pause it
sorry I they're just hearing the speaker
in the background yeah I gotta oh that's
gonna do a workaround all right it's not
sure exactly why it's happening Dan is
working around
I'm working around and uh as we work
around let me try to talk about
something that doesn't require I'm gonna
send it in the other bus go ahead and go
ahead and play one more time okay we're
sending it to the other bus then I get
to the other bus how to Pikachu a [__]
y'all the Pikachu is a level five six I
believe it's working now let me just get
confirmation and Dan sent it not to the
short bus
but the uh full-size bus this time no
yep no I'm seeing lots of no's but I
don't think they caught up yet yeah no
it's no it's working
[Music]
okay okay let me play this video I'm
just gonna play for you guys because you
heard it whatever but they didn't they
didn't hear it [__] man all right here
here you guys go here's the Pikachu very
strange wolf how to Pikachu a [__] it's
working this is really important that
you guys yeah okay now we got it we'll
pretend like we've never seen it before
I'm gonna react like I've never seen it
it's important you guys know how to
Pikachu a [__] yeah yeah the Pikachu is
a level five sex move so some form of
consent is required now you will need a
wall outlet some spit and a [__] you
won't be missed I need you to set up an
area to [__] this [__] next to a wall
outlet but make sure that the cover is
off of the outlet now while your dick is
still inside of her I want you to make
her suck her fingers once you see the
her fingers are nice and damp I want you
to pull her hand out of her mouth yell
Pikachu and stick her soggy fingers into
the outlet if don't nothing happen right
away start wiggling her fingers around
yeah Pikachu again and hurry up and do
this before she starts asking questions
as soon as you hit the metal prong then
the electrician is going to flow through
her body down to her [__] it's gonna
make her coochie collapse and y'all both
gonna be shocked by the electricity and
by how good this feels get the recovery
time up to about an hour hour and a half
and y'all both should regain
Consciousness if not damn game is game
there it is that was the Super that was
the video that was so important well we
got it we had to play it twice Pikachu a
[__] there it is game is game
um
here's a new one check this one out some
good old stuff at the top of the show
here oh man this is a classic
um
you probably have all seen this but
never asked you students to do anything
we wouldn't do ourselves
come on
I didn't know you she's oh my god
[Applause]
dude she committed so hard full send and
this dude is like straight up they I
don't know how they were so on the
different page here so ask teachers
would never ask you students to do
anything fun to ourselves
[Music]
I love the instructor he doesn't give a
[__] dude
holy crap what is happening I didn't
know you she's oh my God you're not
laughing either she's like seriously
injured love that for her
she's being truthful though wouldn't ask
the students to
do anything that you wouldn't do prayer
respect respect here's a bunch of morons
in the audience creaming their pants
over thirty five hundred dollars
easy is the fun there there are some
people presents I think it's pretty cool
so I didn't say it's not cool
I said they're creamy in their pants
because as long as you're cool with me
creaming my pants then whatever oh you
cream your pants anytime you want we've
established that just happens sometimes
yeah
it's a well-established phenomenon yeah
all right I I don't think I think it's
cool maybe I'm not you know what I mean
no I I just think that the price is
ridiculous as well but it is like cool
to [__] buy that outright yeah like
of the average American who can go there
and just be like here's 3 500 they're
gonna have to get like a straight up
alone yeah on this [__] well good news
apple is now offering uh banking
services right yeah good good interest
rate on those psychotic you know it's
like even if I was to get it how could I
enjoy it when like no one I know has it
my wife doesn't have it my niece is no
one my family's not gonna have it just
be annoying well I don't have it don't
worry I don't want to share that you're
buying cam
I think so I think I'm gonna give it a
shot yeah why not I mean I'm looking
forward to seeing it if you bring it to
the office I want to like check it out
and stuff sure yeah I mean like how much
is your computer it's you know I'd view
it as buying a new computer you know
what I mean right except if you spend 3
500 on a computer you have a computer
yeah come on yeah there's computing
it works with my computer too
right can you play Diablo 4 on this mask
no you can't play it on a Mac
it might be a Mac version blizzard is
actually pretty good about releasing Mac
versions of their game so there there
might be there might be so maybe there
is a Apple Vision yeah enjoy it buy it
God bless you God bless
Apple Vision Pro starts at 34.99 it will
be available early next year on
apple.com and at Apple retail stores in
the US was that a garage sounded more
like ooh like oh let me hear that you're
gonna have to grab that response from
the crowds act that's useful start you
got it at 34.99 it will be available I
think they're all going like oh they're
creaming their plants at all no they're
they're upset yeah they're disappointed
as [__] yeah
here's the thing Apple doesn't give a
[__] they're probably like our margin
makes this 2 000. they're like no
3 500 because we're [__] Apple
that's what it is for a first time I
think it's even lower
the margins
maybe I mean listen uh who knows but
that's insane at 34.99 it will be
available early next he really said that
price in these increasingly strange days
he said that price real confident too
very cheaperly thirty five hundred he
should have been like and the price is
and I'm sorry about this guys I gotta
brace you for this one
Apple Vision Pro starts at 34.99
you can't reward this price gouging this
psycho [__] they want they just want you
to be in debt they want your debt Apple
wants to own your soul don't you
understand they want your bank account
they want your VR goggles they want your
phone they want your computer they're
making a car
don't you people get it how much is the
car gonna cost we were talking about
that at the office the other day like
with how they price everything that's
gonna be like a quarter million dollar
car I don't think so because I think
they want to hit a spot where
it's obviously going to be more
expensive than like
a Camry but I think they're gonna maybe
like 50 000 something like that you know
oh it's like just a little
I think it's gonna be way more who can
afford to buy a car that's
250 000 well man I think the best match
at the Tesla
yeah maybe maybe I agree with Zach yeah
yeah apparently Apple's making a car
that's awesome yeah they'll drive you
right straight to their Bank the Apple
Bank it has it actually it can
automatically self-drive to your grocery
Apple grocery store to the Apple Bank to
the Apple University uh Apple uh daycare
Apple
apple apple pie
yeah it's gonna be awesome man [__]
love Apple dude
they're the best
oh
more murder Tick Tock guy I heard you
guys loud and clear I'm not gonna invite
him on
I I after a further reflection I agree
that some people are just not really
worth talking to yeah and murder Tech
the guy who's horny for murder probably
not now I like making fun of him
definitely but inviting him on to ask uh
I don't know although I do think I would
do a good job of challenging him and
make him look crazy but he already looks
crazy I can't make him look crazier than
he already looks did you see it went
over my head at the time but did you see
people point out how later in the same
episode
you made a joke about Pierce Morgan
inviting on a murderer
I don't remember we were talking about
Pierce Morgan because he had the the
prankster kid on or whatever yeah and
you were like Pierce he'll just invite
anybody on he'll just invite straight up
murder to debate if murders okay or
whatever I I don't remember I don't
remember anything hold on okay fair
enough I don't know nothing about no
this is gonna be so this boy is really
blowing up on on social media he's
actually I heard he's going to be the
third wheel and friction fresh and fit
with this really cool ideas cool be hard
to believe that's why I'm gonna pull out
the credentials I was about to film a
tick tock and a legit demon pulled up on
me here's the video
you bro
you asked me if I want to suck you off
you know who you need is Jesus Christ
bro and you need to okay I you called
him bro you were on Grindr you told him
to meet you here okay I know exactly
what happened yeah that was my immediate
thought as well like what are you
talking about dude he's like what do you
mean I uh we just had sex last week
okay here's the video you bro
you asked me if I want to suck you off
you know who you know you do though
that's the sad part
but it's not safe for him he does Jesus
Christ bro and you need to repent
no I'm serious man you don't just pull
up on someone say do you want to suck me
off
Jesus Christ and if you don't repent
you'll go to hell
[__] [__] doing this
he 100 invited him the message that I
was giving was about second Timothy
chapter 3 verse two this is going to be
hard to believe such a weirdo but here's
the my favorite evolution of this story
you know I've been talking about my boy
Big Nick
who uh turned into like
yo that man's brain on Jesus was just it
rotted from the inside out he seemed
like a nice guy sweet guy when he
started learning about Jesus he turned
into like this misogynistic bigoted
[__] weirdo and um
to tie it all together Big Nick
what does it mean is collaborating
with murder porn guy
is that awesome
that's like the perfect evolution of big
mix Trent metamorphosis
pick it out let's see I need to be a man
in this generation you see the world is
going to teach you that in order to be a
true man you need to go around and sleep
with a bunch of different women get a
bunch of sports cards and become a
millionaire a billionaire all of that is
alive from the pits of Hell to be a man
is to be humble rather than seeking the
approval and exaltation of others it
says in Matthew chapter 23 verse 12.
what he was saying though wait they they
they do not know what humble means I
think I'm in a [__] I'm a supporter
Matthew pointed up to the murder called
Matthew 20. his whole message it was
like the ant the anti-andrew Tate that
he just laid out right there he was he
was [__] on Tate and all the alpha
Bros is this a recent Story by big Nikki
yep to celebrate pride month
Covenant awareness month because the
rainbow belongs to God and always will
even when a sinful and Fallen World
thinks they can hijack it for an evil
purpose all right I'm back out
never mind not joining the murder cult
he's such a [__] hateful chill out
and I don't again I don't say troll
because of his stature that I don't joke
about that that's just not a fair thing
to laugh about I'd say that like
in the sense of like a troll
I mean if you Google troll
and you go to a drawing of a classroom
so I mean here you go you know what I
mean just a demonic little troll and
little
trolls are oftentimes depicted quite
large yeah fantasy literature so yeah
the stone trolls that uh Bilbo
speaks to until Daybreak comes and then
they are turned to stone by daylight
that's right they were big and that big
[__] that broke in Hogwarts he
was a troll there it is
and just to clarify it I'm not talking
about these trolls which are very small
in stature and quite strange looking
right these are not the trolls I'm
talking about when I call him a troll
right like we're talking about the the
trolls of innathual swamp from the
Everquest franchise good very good troll
uh we're talking about uh uh Lord of the
Rings troll right so let's see yes so I
mean that's badass I mean he's huge and
awesome kind of a combo guy it's kind of
a compliment yep
little [__] weirdo troll
foreign
to be a man is to be humble rather than
seeking the approval and exaltation of
others it says in Matthew chapter 23
verse says in Matthew 23 12 if you have
sex with an unmarried woman you must
castrate her mind and body bury her in
your backyard and then ask for
forgiveness do it again
castrated
to be humble rather than seeking the
approval and exaltation of others it
says in Matthew chapter 23 verse 12 and
whoever exalts himself will be humbled
and he who is humble himself will be
exalted to be humble means to have a low
Viewpoint of yourself the world wants to
boost you up boost you up your name
everywhere but God says be humble and
the Bible also says in Matthew 20 28
that the son of man did not come down to
be served but to serve and give his life
I don't know if these guys the pope was
just here and he was talking mad [__]
yeah
you wanna know something kind of funny I
mean it's [__] up but it's funny
because it's him is that shortly after
posting this uh PRI anti-pride post he
uh his car broke down in the middle of
the night and he kept his own stories
like God is testing me you guys testing
me oh God is great and then like he's
like waiting for Triple H's been like
three hours he's like bro you can't
listen you can't invoke God every time
you need to call Triple A he's not God
doesn't care you know what I mean about
your car running what happened to the
humility what happened to humility dude
you're not the center of the story man
yep God is really testing me boy
my check engine light went on had to
call AAA
God's been real testing me dude so many
people are crashing I see the views
going down everyone's saying crash and
it's worse [__] you YouTube we're going
back to Twitter
[Music]
[__] tweet at them again
and I'm gonna ask them can you fix this
[__] what is going on
team YouTube
there's also so
whatever I'll just do them team YouTube
[__] you
the crashing issue is still happening
and worse than it was please do
something
about it
it's been weeks
all right guys please go there God is
testing me right now boy
that's right God
has put a poke a bug in the iOS YouTube
app to test us God is testing me today
I'm gonna write that God is testing me
God is good he's testing me God is good
God is good he's kind of a dick testing
me thank you God what do you like it's
like a fetish it's like a domination
fetish now you know it's a test and not
a punishment like how do you distinguish
that because that you know they say that
like
oh the hurricanes are like because uh
gay marriage or whatever that's a
punishment but how do we know that's not
just a test and vice versa
does God know you're gay
yeah
um
listen God is testing me Lord let me
said let's move to triller
when God made me murder that woman
he was testing you think that God Made
You Gay God made me gay
yeah uh there's my tweet please go up
please send them screenshots comment I
mean God damn I'm annoyed with this [__]
it's I feel like it's really affecting
our views because I see it climbing and
climbing and then all of a sudden it
just crashed down like 2000 for no
reason yeah because you have to imagine
every time it Mass crashes for like half
the live viewers a percentage of them
are just like I [__] it I'm not coming
back yeah for sure understandably
because it's annoying so
yeah that sucks here's the thing a big
one
if someone's if you keep punishing
someone they're like thank you thank you
thank you that's like a fetish
thank you mistress thank you please
punish me more thank you something yeah
media something
thank you perhaps
Perhaps it is please step on my dick
again
Daddy
uh so anyway yeah on that note uh we
gotta do some let me finish this ransom
for many God In the Flesh came down and
became a servant to his creation it's
time to stop being a problem if you want
to truly be exhausted by God oh yeah if
God's so good why Triple A take so long
[__] I think you could have sped that
up check mate you're telling God can set
his own damn son down here to exalt
himself and he can't get Triple A there
in 30 minutes give me a break
[__] oh you have to humble yourself you
have to stop seeking the glorification
like Triple L
got him the murder porn guy is like so
creepy the way he's just staring and
Silent like he's just silently there you
know you know big Nick was like I like
this guy I want to collab with him the
guy who says I used to watch
porn of women being murdered they used
to fantasize about murdering my wife
when we had sex big snakes like I like
this dude I'ma hop in a car with this
guy I'm gonna get I'm gonna get at night
it's dark I want to get alone how's
everyone you know has he been seen since
then I was about to say his car broke
down right after this maybe I I don't
know if it was before or after I wonder
if somebody maybe I was wondering
siphoned his gas you know what I'm
saying um I was wondering if it's before
and the murder dude picked him up it was
like the last guy that would answer the
phone for him he was he was the Triple A
man yeah
this world and people in your life
because God should be the only one that
you should be seeking glorification from
humble yourself and God will exalt you
and that's what it is to be a man being
stranded on the freeway and crying about
it on Instagram loser L God idiot idiot
all right thank you to them thank you
these morons
[Applause]
one more I didn't see this Jared Leto
climbing a wall
what is this [__]
can you meet it thank you
like what are you doing dude
you know you're not the Joker right
you're not even like a good Joker
and you're climbing the [__] this is
morbius activity this is when Joe
corrected all right
this is definitely not Dallas Buyers
Club which is the when you actually got
an award be more like that I wish you
would
um
can I say this
oh no I
based off the fact you're talking about
that movie probably not
yeah no no I mean
it's there
it's there for anybody that knows they
know be more you don't even you don't
even have to say it they know be more
debt like Dallas buyer club and less
like you please yep right thank you yeah
that's sufficient what did you do he
went up and came down
he just went up and he came down wait he
didn't even well he just gave up he gave
up
he went up he came down dude what the
hell yo
I thought it was more of in time dude
what the hell all right let's thank our
sponsors and then we're gonna get into
this uh a b
a show the a b proofs
well yep yep so thank you first to
um Express
VPN we love our sponsors us
using the internet without expressvpn is
like forgetting to mute yourself on zoom
and everyone hears you trash talk your
co-workers or even worse what was that
Jeff guy's name tubing you don't Jeff
tubing yourself boy yep and that's what
that goes for all of you in the council
too yeah I'm talking to you keep your
dicks in your pants people
it may just be a bit of harmless banter
but what happens if your boss overhears
you talking about his receding hairline
I know who's not
you might be talking [__] about me but
not about my receding hairline
yes so here's why you need a VPN to be
honest internet service providers know
every single website you visit ips's can
sell this very private information to
add companies and Tech Giants who used
your data to Target you creepy weird
hate it
and expressvpn reroutes your network
data through a secure encrypted tunnel
so your ISP cannot see or sell your
online activity
it's super simple to use if you fire up
the app you click one button it's rated
number one by a ton of tech
journalist Cena and tech radar it works
on phones laptops and even routers so
everyone who uses the router and is on
your Wi-Fi can be protected that's
pretty slick
I like you know the sense of security
I like being able to connect and make
websites think I'm from a different
country I love that
great
you know
you'd be surprised if you go to like uh
England Netflix there's a whole new
world of content there my friends
Japan Whole New World mm-hmm
protect your online privacy by visiting
expressvpn.com H3 today that's exp r e s
s vpn.com H3 and you can get an extra
three months free
at expressvpn.com H3 thank you to our
lovely sponsor
expressvpn we love you
they get a hottie
we love honey
today's episode is sponsored by PayPal
honey the easy way to save money when
shopping on your iPhone or computer
here's the deal just do it just install
honey
it's so worth it there's no downside
it's going to save you a ton of money
guaranteed
here's how it works it manually searches
the internet
for coupon oh no no
automatically not manually
manual is when your dumb ass does it
yeah none of that
so it automatically searches the whole
internet for the best coupon code and
then it automatically applies it at
checkout you just have to click one
button installing it on your browser
takes two clicks it couldn't be easier
it's free to use
free shopping tool it scours the whole
internet for the best promo code
you don't have to think I have saved so
much money I mean these are all genuine
savings
most of them are from Elsa
from you guys
my crew
and like just try I mean really you have
nothing to lose imagine you're shopping
at one of your favorite sites when you
click checkout honey button appears and
all you have to do is Click apply coupon
wait a few seconds is honey searches for
coupons you can find for that site and
if honey finds a working coupon guess
what the price drops dude
wow I love that man
I I just I don't use the internet
without it man it's just it's just like
that you don't even have to think about
it also honey doesn't just doesn't work
on desktops now it actually works on
your iPhone too
uh just activate it on Safari on your
phone and save on the go so if you don't
already have honey you could be straight
up missing out and by getting it you'll
be doing yourself a solid and supporting
this show
so get PayPal honey for free at
joinhoney.com H3 that's joinhoney.com
H3 let's try it you it's it's seriously
it's a no-brainer just just do it trust
me and uh do it thank you to honey I
appreciate them very much great great
sponsor love them
and finally the one the only it's
stamps.com
stamps.com is revolutionized how people
mail and ship
in this modern day
the post office is just not it
it's just not it girl
so you know with so much of the world
digitized and automated why are you even
going to the post office doesn't make
sense let's be real stamps.com is going
to do the hard part for you while saving
you money and making it more convenient
print it from your home you can print
postage from your home you they're going
to send you a scale
you use the scale to measure your
envelope or package then you print out
the postage you put it on your package
and then you then they come get it
you can put it out in front of your door
if you have a bunch of packages they'll
come get it that's crazy you can put it
in your PO in your mailbox they'll come
get it you could do it in a Dropbox it's
so freaking convenient that's crazy you
don't have to think about it dude I have
spent long hours in the post office man
this I would have killed for this
service when I was in there
here's a great part
um the postage rates just increased
again but because of stamps.com has this
massive bargaining because they have
like over a million partners
they have negotiated unbeatable rates
with USPS and UPS up to 84 percent off
what
what I know they've been in the business
for 25 years
indispensable to over a million
businesses it's just what it is guys
um I'm a huge fan of this product and I
highly recommend it they're a great
sponsor and a great service I love them
yeah so avoid the hassle and get started
with stamps.com today sign up with the
promo code H3 for a special offer that
includes four week trial plus free
postage and
and a free digital skin oh my God yeah
no long-term commitments or contracts
just go to stamps.com Click the
microphone at the top of the page and
enter code H3 thank you to all of our
sponsors please consider
supporting one of our great sponsors
thank you guys so much thank you
love that
I feel like that would have taken me 20
minutes that would how long was that
that would have taken me 20 minutes dude
um yeah no you knocked it out pretty
quick 46 minutes well done six minutes
that's pretty good yeah
all right so we are we are at the moment
that everybody's been waiting for
I'm gonna I need to pee first uh uh a b
okay but I don't know if you want to cue
it up yeah queued up yeah okay I'll be
right back so
this segment uh was inspired by uh
recently we were doing the meme of uh
Ethan breaking down the door and we were
saying that was such a Michael Scott
thing to do and then after that
play along I dressed up as Jim on Friday
and seeing some of the Reddit posts I
realized that people have been talking
about this on Reddit for years about
Ethan being Michael and who everybody is
in the office who's our office character
and I'm surprised like so many of the
posts were so different for the most
part everyone said that Ethan's Michael
but besides that uh they were pretty
different
and
I plan on defending myself today because
I'm seeing a lot of people say that I'm
Ryan I did not agree with this
it's [__] slander it's kind of
racist but I'll get into that racist
it's racist oh yeah we're not [__]
around today
so yeah yesterday we're looking at news
stories and there's nothing that good
there was a few things and I was like
you know what let's do the office
segment and I started on it and I
underestimated how long it would take
and I propose it to Ethan like super
late and he's like oh that sounds fun
and um yeah I just underestimated it and
I've been up all night doing it so I
hope you guys enjoy it
smash that [__] like button who
do you think you are Dan
who do I we I mean we went over this
Oscar or Toby right those are the ones
that everybody kind of agreed on
are you gonna have some big twist for us
maybe oh there's some twists yeah
um I'm I'm Packer Todd packer
no no no no no
the exact opposite
uh but yeah some of these people
some of them are a mix it's kind of hard
and this a blend like a nice one yes
wine yeah
but the new zodiac sign
what's up
it's the new zodiac sign what's your
office character yeah exactly I'm a
I'm uh I don't even know I don't I don't
know I actually don't know the office
that well I only ever watched it at
friend's house that's another thing too
Dwight's son
Kevin
that's another thing too I realized that
not everyone watches the office so
there's a description next to everyone
so that everyone can enjoy so thank you
very much do I need to roll it or you
can
uh you need to roll it but I could
I see I can guide you just tell me what
to do
um
here it is gonna show you the world
this is it
ABS Magnus opium yeah
the Magnus opium this uh title card took
me so [__] long and it was annoying
me because it was like super late I'm
like damn I know cam could just knock
this out in like five seconds but he was
asleep I don't want to wake him up but
yes the H3 office
let's just jump right into it
wait before we start Ian
what button do I press to just uh take
his screen full screen
you have to hover over oh you're gonna
make me do this like this just smash
that button just leave the mouse on on
that one and press C just don't move it
don't move it Dan
don't move it just don't move it there's
no reason to move it because I got the I
got the timer over here I got the mixing
board I got my mouse is busy I don't
even that was real busy
move don't worry about it yeah let's go
okay take it away so we must settle the
discussion once and for all proceed
first of all you don't have to watch the
office as I mentioned character types
will be described consider it a look
back at some of the crew's best moments
the subreddit has been debating this
topic for years
please proceed
this is a scientific explanation my
results are based on subreddit posts
comments and most importantly my own
opinion because I know and work with
these people every day
compelling stuff yeah very some of these
will need more explanation than others
let's begin with Ethan okay
here we go
can you believe it can you believe it
now in all honesty clearly we all know
you're Michael but I was shocked at some
of the things that were said some of the
things you've done in the conversations
you had were so spot on initially I
wanted to show the videos but they all
got claimed I was trying to be tricky
with it I recorded everything on my
phone it sucks yeah but this still works
if you know who I am who are you who do
you see yourself as
hold up hold up
I'll show you exactly who I am in the
office
and I think I'm going to hit it right
my internet not working what's the deal
here it is
hold on who's Sam I like this music
holding on
holding on I'm okay here I'm trying to
find a good screenshot
of it but open image a new tab
here this is me
hmm what's his name what's that actor's
name Ethan Idris uh it's actually Ibiza
Elba yeah wow
good job okay
I see a lot of similarities between his
character
right for example the effect you have
everybody respects him uh-huh
right you're super handsome
shockingly handsome Michael's handsome
I agree
oh yeah a lot of people are handsome
though yeah that's true
or if you if you guys aren't gonna give
me that one which I maybe I granted as a
stretch
then you have to give me this one
[Music]
okay I got you alone are you just proven
your money here let me just distract the
audience with this real quick I see I
have this option this is me
if you're not gonna give me
Idris then you have to give me David
Wallace oh I forgot about David Wallace
okay everyone loves Michael a lot more
than those two I'm just saying yep
David's cool no David's the man he's
he's respected he's in his field you
know he he calls he's a shot caller and
he's uh he doesn't take [__] from nobody
um
all kinds of similarities sure okay
let's proceed
I I proceeded also I shout out to Reiner
Harvey for making this on you're just
inserting a little thing of yourself as
Jim Reiner Harvey's if you know we love
him dude you're so Ryan right now it's
just sad yeah like your effort to do
this let's uh proceed
example of how similar Ethan and Michael
are now before you play this video I
wanted to say that the actual scene he
says let me ask you is there another
word for Mexican that's less offensive
and then Oscar says but Mexican's not
offensive and to which Michael replies
I forgot to replies but it says in the
meme but I just want to point that out
because it's like
Verbatim what you say here go ahead you
know we were wondering
if we should do something for Cinco de
Mayo like we did on
St Patrick's Day but I says
I'm definitely gonna be canceled I don't
know what we're planning or what we're
gonna do but I'm gonna get I'm gonna get
in trouble
see don't even somehow I feel like even
that's racist why I just feel it Dan
just playing I can't touch this one
vaguely
[Laughter]
not as bad you know we're wondering
but uh I see the parallel yeah maybe a
slight parallel
and also just to point out that Oscar
maybe Dan just a little spoiler but that
also lines up what a shock
okay let's move on
really sad that I could not show this
video because his Godfather voice does
sound a lot like yours
I guess we'll just have to take your
word for it yeah
um
[Music]
the gamer just played the audio
uh I don't I don't know
I I listen to the audio right
are you a second of it
okay please hold I'm in
let's be thorough here
let's be thorough like when we test them
test the clips
it's because it's like 100 of the clip
when it's spread out in a broadcast in
my work yeah it's true
and stuff too I mean this is yeah
Community debate for a while so yeah
it's time stamped
we got it okay
there it is so don't show it damn I will
not sure
oh Michael this is just for family but
I'm The Godfather it is really funny but
you know that can be confusing at a
christening because you are not The
Godfather
are you talking to me okay your turn I
won't play anymore
oh I actually would even potentially put
forward that his is better than mine
well he mixed his with uh
Taxi Driver like you do as well just
point that out you talking to me I don't
do that yeah you do you mix it with Taxi
Driver yeah dinero you talking to me
that's Taxi Driver
you know I've never thought about that I
never say you talking to me that's a
Michael Scott thing I don't I don't go
you talking to me you do the denirois
and everything
no I'm doing Marlin brand yeah you
started with Marlon Brando but sometimes
it turns into demo
that's a fabrication okay
oh by the way guys if you if there are
any that I'm any uh like instances that
I missed please post it on the subreddit
because I am curious because I'm I'm
amazed at how many similarities there
are so
keep it going
proceed please okay uh so do you guys
remember that one time Ethan tried to
edit one of his old videos and it went
horribly wrong he tried to take just one
thing out and then you accidentally
condense the whole video to just that we
can tell the story it's I mean we've
told we've talked it yeah you told it on
uh see you next Tuesday
oh really yeah I don't know if you've
ever actually told the story on the main
podcast
line Channel Okay so
we talked about this recently because of
the reach in Babylon reach that and the
old Joey salads video when I was calling
out what a racist piece of shitty is and
I was reading
out some of the super racist comments
that was left on Joey's video just to
show like how he's just causing all this
racism and animosity based on this fake
[__] I was reading the comments verbatim
and I was saying the n-word
horrible I know but that's what happened
okay
so what I did so YouTube has an editing
tool
um where you can cut out
specific parts of the video and so
I went to the back end I said I want to
cut out the n-word I don't I don't want
I don't want to be saying that I just
wanted to cut out like so it was like a
bleep so I wasn't saying it
but I'm still reading the comments so
what happened
as I got confused I thought I isolated
that part that I wanted to cut of me
saying the n-word
and then I hit process it takes like 24
hours but when I came back and saw the
finished video which was about 20
minutes
what was left was about three seconds my
20 minute video was three seconds long I
said what the hell I play it it's
literally just me saying the n-word
so I managed to cut out everything in
the whole video except me saying the
n-word
uh which is clearly not what I wanted to
do right and then at that point
it just became unsalvageable and just a
straight up a race
that reminds me of when Michael Scott
wanted to send one email to one of his
friends of a picture of him and his
girlfriend he sent it to the whole
company
right ah I do remember that happening
similar it was like a topless photo
that he meant to send to one person and
blasted it to the whole world I see the
parents who's unlisted
uh yeah well it wasn't at the time no it
never went out publicly I had it
unlisted uh uh after I did the edit so
it wasn't a public video where it's just
me going can you imagine there's a video
with like 10 million views it's just
three seconds long it's just me being
like n-word that's it
I'm down you can back me up YouTube's
editing tool it sucks I understand very
misleading it's very misleading I I
would have perhaps been slightly I would
have maybe triple checked if if it was
such a sensitive I thought I did no I I
was like okay I got it he mentioned the
n-word yesterday yeah no they're they're
wording and their interface and
everything is not very intuitive so uh I
don't see how it happened I see how it
happened I don't see the barrel oh we
got a lot more we keep going
uh there should be a photo there I don't
know why you're not seeing it maybe if I
hit next there there it is okay so
you guys are making like the same sound
almost in these clips but uh yeah you
guys are both sick under a table and
letting everyone know you're sick what's
the one on the left room of me that's
when you had like horror well I have to
be more specific uh
is it
Mr verified yeah it was exactly it was
it was before Mr verified you were like
super sick you had some kind of shawarma
that [__] you up
oh okay I got [__] by the Shawarma yep
and then what was wrong with Michael
Scott
I don't know what's wrong with him
um
yeah I want usually I'd ask YouTube
regarding the n-word thing
to help me fix it but I was too
embarrassed so I wasn't gonna be like
can you guys revert this I I straight up
just erased it 10 million people
[Music]
adorable okay we'd like to know when
we're sick
okay well it's more about the loudly
crying about it right yeah dramatic not
always you see the boss I was not being
dramatic I was very ill in that day yeah
yeah that's fair that's fair thank you
okay the next one is really good
sure if you don't watch the office
you've heard this meme of Michael
screaming no
I found it it is on his Tick Tock it has
1.8 million views no Yo God no I'm not
sorry that's a part two part one has 6.2
million views no um
and so if you proceed to the next slide
I was just wait what was I reacting to
it was about some Tick Tock trying to
get any crazy amount of views I forget
which one it was that's all that's it I
found it it was on his Tick Tock it has
one if you go to the next slide so I was
just curious I didn't make no edits I
just dropped
our the office footage over our footage
and the way it lines up is insane it's
crazy that this almost lines up
perfectly 1.8 million views no Yo
God no I'm sorry that's a part two part
one has 6.2 million views
listen wow we both yelled no big deal
okay come on
I just realized I haven't said big whoop
and like a big one decades uh what a
wow big whoop you never said no in your
life okay let's go to this next one no
no exactly Crowder and Crowder said no
so this speaks for itself just play it
yep we call that uh in my family a ham
sandwich now I did not even call him a
ham sandwich and by the way I don't even
want to blame Anissa because we're just
and this Anisa didn't call my ham
sandwich either we're just kind of
shooting the [__]
I don't think anyone called him a ham
sandwich he is a ham sandwich
[Laughter]
but the idea was thrown around everyone
too so I'd go for that
what's that have to do with Michael's
spot
I researched this like a [__] content
cupless or Court let's keep going we
call that uh
okay there's an episode the office where
Michael gets these jeans and Pam's like
I don't know what happened we put on
those jeans he just something comes out
of them and this is the one only time
we've seen you in jeans I can oh is this
me okay this isn't the office no no no
here's me in the jeans everyone's
feeling it
is that even so funny
now this this is worth the membership
right now
I swear you guys even dance similar
let's go baby Michael never wore jeans
in the show
he did like a after he got those jeans
he was doing like casual Fridays or
something
okay we both wear jeans once wow you got
me good
please proceed
I proceeded so I'm sure everyone is
familiar with the situation at this time
but uh
there was a poor pregnant woman locked
in a bathroom next door I broke her out
being the here I am
and then Ethan's like oh I could do that
which Michael Scott has done many times
when it comes to like racing I think it
was like racing to white or something
and he's like I could do it and then
this is what proceeded okay
we need another person to help me kick
because there was a double kicker
damn I mean I've got no run up here I
mean this is a joke
I mean come on
you need a kicker yeah I need a double
kick okay all right so I'm gonna start
by um yeah
that's pretty heavy don't hurt yourself
yeah that is that is quite heavy here
come here Kim help me everybody's saying
YouTube crashed for them again dude I'm
so over this what is wrong with that man
views are going up though I've been
trying to tell these [__] guys about
this for so long it's like
I feel like they don't even know still
what what it is they don't even know
still
um go to the YouTube forums please if
you have time YouTube what is that I
remember I don't know what that is it's
like a help support Forum go to The
Forum tell them what's up that's old
school
yeah it is horrible they're pretty
active there all right here we go back
to the Michael Scott
that is fairly thick
[Laughter]
can I just say this is such a Michael
Scott thing right now
[Music]
you're implanting it in people's minds
this is where it came from it all came
from this yeah it's Michael Scott you're
putting in my damn people beautiful we
have it on camera
thank you you know do you think I'm
Michael Scott Lena
she said yes
oh yeah and who are you then Lena you'll
see
yeah
it all comes together all right we're
both kicking yeah okay aim for up here
okay right no no I I can down here of
course we're trying to run
everybody
we're trying to replicate it
around
here Michael always talks to Ryan one
day all right
three two way one
okay so what that's more sick falling
off the walls and [__] okay now it's
just easy camera all right one more one
more you already did that I said just
film man okay
three two one
a little bit yeah that thing is [__]
bro you got this all right I'm coming in
Olivia are you okay in there Elon I'm
sorry if it gets hurt are you okay
she's pregnant you guys all right Olivia
stay away from the door that's what I
said yesterday stay away from the door
ow
was that a joke
oh
yeah I just love breaking stuff
oh yeah
I gotta watch this whole day yeah
there's no way there's no [__] way
right
yeah go ahead now let's see after we've
loosened it up there's no way you're
getting in there okay we're good okay
oh like a maniac though
I feel like you have issues seeing the
way you throw yourself at that door I
mean it was on camera
that was that was really well done okay
hold on
now you now notice that's it okay okay I
will admit I don't know why what this
has to do with Michael Scott but I will
admit that that door was you know
thicker than I anticipated
sure and you were very uh you were very
impressive the way you attacked that
door thank you what's stunning thank you
yeah this next slide might be a little
tough for you to see but did you know
that Michael Scott we need another
person Miss quotes different things I
don't know anything about that
what's that have to do with me I don't
know let's see all right we got to get
on chat GPS I'm super curious about that
yeah you know okay all right Jeff BTC
agrees with me everybody yeah that's
what I'm supposed to chat GPS or
whatever [__] it's called I want to
compare it to chat gdp4 I've been so in
I've been chatting with chat GPS
I consulted with um chat GTP on this
decline [__] meltdown over chat GTP
being like a libtard or something
chat gp4
right okay so they go they go to chat
GPS say hey write me a you know
everybody and their aunt has access to
this JJ chat isn't it just open to the
public dude chat gbt is [__] amazing
one more thing yeah what the hell dude I
said I write that time
I got a real one stuck in let me check
EBT is [__] amazing let's ask chat
gbt one more thing 2023 can you check
that on sure we gotta get on chat GPS
I'm super curious about that you know
okay
agrees with me everybody yeah that's
what I'm supposed oh restarted yeah
xxxtentacion
foreign
it's hard those three it's like three
random letters it's like a weird acronym
how am I supposed to know that Michael
Scott said nc3 instead of MP3 let's see
I I don't have that oh you don't have it
check it out yeah he said nc3 yeah
instead of MP3 correct I get that
yeah GPS especially when when the MP3 is
new and you're trying you don't have you
have a really it's a new technology yeah
so speaking of that GPT if you could
please go to the next slide
okay interesting so this you went really
uh to the experts on this huh I go hard
in the paint you want me to read her you
got it I can read it go ahead how is
Ethan Klein like Michael Scott
Ethan Klein the host of HP podcast and
Michael Scott a fictional character from
The Office share some similarities in
terms of their humor and occasional
awkwardness but they have different
backgrounds and context both Ethan and
Michael have a tendency to make jokes
that may come off as inappropriate or
cringe-worthy they both have
self-deprecating sense of humor and
sometimes struggle with social cues
however it's important to note that
Michael Scott is a character created by
the writers of the office and is
portrayed by the actor Steve Carell
while Ethan Klein is a real person and a
contact Dave that's important to know
that he's not real this [__] Ethan is
very real
thanks
but there there's your God
right there okay what so we both make
awkward jokes nice I'm just saying Dan
send me the password for chat GPT I
gotta ask a house a b like Michael Scott
it doesn't know who I am I tried oh
really yeah it stopped at September same
2021. shame isn't it
anyways next slide please
it's a shame chat gbt doesn't know who
you are I would go to the next slide
before you keep going in on this because
I mean the fact that this robot knows
who I am very Michael Scott right now
I'm telling you he's this robot puts
respect on my name yeah
next slide is hug it out [__] which is
what
Michael tells Dwight kind of shows that
like wait you just said your delay yeah
well no you don't know some people are
mixed by the way I think you may be in
the bathroom some people are a mix you
you're literally saying I'm Dwight Maybe
but I would just say this
I like Michael Scott there's a lot of
qualities of Ethan they make him a great
leader and a great man you know
not everybody knows all the good things
he did he does
I like this when I first started I was
doing content Court I think it was the
second one I was super nervous and I was
super antsy and like shaky and stuff and
he called me after and said hey man you
all right don't worry about it he's
doing good don't stress
don't be so hard on yourself that didn't
happen and I was like I love you and
he's like that's [__] weird take it
easy no the second part didn't happen
but you did call me I did yeah oh that
was nice to me there's a lot of good
things you do that no one know about
the story when me and Lino were driving
to Michigan
what's what happened we were driving to
Michigan during break because
uh we missed our flight or something I
forget what it was oh we didn't get a
flight in time to my brother-in-law's
wedding and we're ready to drive
and you like kept calling me on the
highway and I didn't realize and you're
like dude don't drive I'm like oh it's
fine I'm I'm used to driving I like it
you're like no dude please is it money
thing I'm like no it's not a money thing
and you're like
I just sent you money for a ticket
please buy a plane ticket
bought a million tickets to go home when
I first started nice
never told anyone thank you bro
thank you for saying that
touching this is my favorite part
um that's really sweet
that was really sweet of you to do thank
you
Ethan by the way I just found out my uh
cousin's dog
died yesterday and yeah Hawaii
yeah you need to go to the funeral
drowned and they're they're doing an
on-site funeral out there but
I'm gonna have to swim so you're gonna
have to find out who you are first you
have to find out which office character
before Ethan makes it first of all a b
this man works his heart out he works
his finger to the Bone tell him
yeah and when this dude and Lena two of
the greatest people the truest people in
the world they're about to waste their
precious beautiful time off driving yeah
oh [__] that my boy's flying and that's
what it is thank you baby for honoring
me we're the best thanks bro moving on
they're gonna try to make a joke out of
it no no I wasn't trying to make a joke
it's trying to get a plane ticket out of
it yeah once we find out it's a big joke
it would all make sense once we find out
who Dan is
so there are a few people in here
two that I had trouble placing and I'm
open to the audience telling me
um but Ila was one of them
I don't think that's hard at all that
one told me yeah I don't hate this I
mean it's not bad but Eli just has so
many I don't know she has like all the
cool aspects of everyone
with none of the bad so
it was tough she doesn't have bad
aspects I feel like she's like a totally
wholesome I mean she's a little dorky
but yeah she's a little dorky but he
looks cool okay this is interesting I
don't hate it I just I found this on the
subreddit so there you go I like it you
know what I mean that's how it fits I
got no problem with that one Michael I'm
okay being Michael
okay and when I see this beautiful these
beautiful happy people
now let's move on to some dark [__]
right here
so should we do some kind of pull to to
I know that people are gonna agree that
I'm Michael Scott I don't think I can no
yeah they're maybe at the maybe at the
end or something I don't know
why let's move on yeah go ahead okay so
Dan is a culmination of these three
characters Oscar
uh Jim I can't think of his name for
some reason and uh Toby
interesting interesting okay I'm
listening why Oscar Oscar the smartest
guy in the office corrects Michael when
passing along false information and just
you know is this just more Digs at me
okay
Ethan villagers out there your main
character the hoop so glad oh [__] what
happened oh God let me go back sorry
okay and to all the biologists out there
so glad that they made the Mandalorian
and I'm so glad they gave it to Johnson
what I gotta go back what the [__] was
that
okay and to all the biologists out there
the biologist
the what I think that goes sir
the biologist the [__] that they made
the Mandalorian and I'm so glad they
gave it to John Favre what's his name
abro Favreau movie he's made except 100.
what
is the only giving them a third of the
credit here wait what the movie is 300
not 100. probably heard about all the
crazies
NTFS non-fungal I was in my um Fifth
Element dumbass yeah real quick I forgot
to include it thank you lobot the robot
for this compilation oh robot thank you
love robot excellent favorite Star Wars
character
oh God damn it God damn it dude okay and
to all the biologies with the NTFS
non-fungible tokens at ft's
I was looking right at it and I still
said it wrong he brought on the wrath of
ye and all of his insane yeah I was fat
that was like my I was in my fat error
here boy
love that
yeah
because now his name is Miami no one
calls him Yi it's it's yay e two Brutus
a210
and it's the man the main perpetrator
you know Juliet No Julius you are Julius
you're Judith this is famous for and I
am Jesus okay we're mixing up our
metaphors here a little bit now dude
he's so you're over correcting I'm not
over correcting music
okay okay he's combative indicator I
agree right
[Laughter]
why Jim okay now this is oh this is
probably not the best day to show that
uh that frame oh yeah we could just skip
that one
yeah all right yeah let me I'll just
explain it basically uh yeah just let me
go to the next frame
Dan is saying that uh that was our Mr
verified competition but let's be honest
I could just have I could just play the
audio okay sure okay here it is would be
happy to have them so this is why Jim
Jim is cool guy who isn't a tryhard so
here it is
Jackie but let's be honest any of these
guys would be happy to have a book what
do you think about that description Dan
well let me see the clip I'm not
familiar with this club roll the clip
we'll check you right oh but of course I
actually don't I I hate the check mark
thing I don't exist on social media I
don't want a blue check yeah Dan says
that but I mean I've been saying it
consistently for like the last month
I feel like they're still kind of Oscar
I don't know that doesn't strike
personally I I feel that
he's literally doing it right now you've
ever fallen for it no he's right Oscar's
too cool for school
I mean
Jim would like go along with it for the
joke I feel he's invested Oscar where
does Oscar just be like this is stupid
you went along with it for the joke well
you kind of Let's watch let's watch all
right let's play is the reverse
psychology play where he acts like he
doesn't care and he does a whole anti
this isn't just for the show though I
was I didn't even want to do this
episode
you're playing right into the Trap you
forced me to do this I can't wait I'm
not God I can't wait you're my boss what
am I gonna do completely refuse
interesting it's giving something yeah
it's giving more Oscar though the I
you're my boss you made me do this
that's like an Oscar that's kind of what
I'm feeling too but it's giving
something though
maybe well he looks at the camera
sometimes too so there you go I mean
that's that's not enough okay now the
Toby compare yeah now this one this one
I can get on board with oh you like
being Toby so if you don't know I just
think it fits if you don't watch the
show he's HR he keeps Michael in check
and is Michael's sworn enemy Michael
hates him irrationally let's give our
full unfiltered reaction to bts's new
music video no no vetoed why Dan I like
it doesn't matter I feel like there's a
lot of misinformation the Bible says as
you all well know and shall shut the
[__] up
is that in one of them Ezekiel yeah
shut the [__] up or face Hell Fire I'm
under the sea can I sing Under the Sea
and with the Jamaican accent or is that
right I mean nothing is going to stop
you is the things well uh homemade feces
right Dan shouldn't stop talking about
that right there in fact I think
that that episode
because I've seen a few screenshots
where you're wearing that outfit I think
that that one killed me huh that that's
Peak that's Peak Ethan yeah that's Pizza
no no not there the one where you're
wearing the blue feces right Dan yeah
at the apex of the of the scale
oh is that what you mean yes yeah yeah
yeah
you said that earlier about a different
clip but then that that's that's
ultimate big boy
that contributes I think around the
beginning of the end though yeah think
of it think of it that way a side note
so me and either were watching
finishing berserk the 1997 one the last
episode you know how insane it is right
yeah Gila fell asleep
oh can you believe that [__] maybe it's
for the best sleep brutal it might be
for the best
no she's invested she's watching every
goddamn episode you fall asleep during
like the craziest you should just
pretend like it ends on a real uplifting
note
no because it was the ending was over
like three episodes oh it was already
gotten into all yeah no it was like
full-on his his arm was in a demon's
mouth
[Music]
this is not a good track we're going
down wait wait this one dance real
serious hold on hold on here homemade
feces right Dan should stop talking
about it this is this is not against
Real Toby on me good track we're going
down people are saying it's illegal yeah
yeah it's obviously illegal
I'm saying people should do it
all right Ian
okay so this one this makes sense and
Jim this hits me as correct
okay I'm interested
I said similar to uh Dan
Ian isn't a try hard he's just cool and
for those who don't know Stanley Stanley
is the guy in the office who just always
looks like he hates his life and Michael
the boss is always trying to engage with
him
and he's just trying to mind his own
business and work we do love Stanley
he's the great one here it is I'm Zach
it's EB love cam Dan Sam and uh what's
your name again Ian
so guys a little hard to do behind the
scenes uh because we're on the office as
much we don't have as much going on as
we do during our normal weeks because
he'll Escape birth so the crew all
agreed to sit in with me and do a little
q a all right all right so upset um
no
nothing nothing at all you guys didn't
cut that part huh see you euthanize Ian
won't put you to death you no William
Zach it's EB okay some of you keep going
backwards
I think I'll restart it restarts well it
missed it missed the ending huh here
I'll play it again we'll euthanize Ian
no Ian likes to die I'm afraid you might
like that yeah that's it yeah okay
okay
Zach is
Toby right what's his name Andy Andy
Zach is Andy let me think about this
he's Musical
likes to break out in the song I have
anger issues
and is Andy an angry guy yeah yeah
rarely but yes he punched the wall he
punches a hole through the drywall
through the drywall he had to go to
anger management yes no he definitely
does can you how's your doo-wop Zach
oh really
I said How's your doo-wop
I'd say it's mid I wouldn't say it's
great okay he has great doo-wop
everything humble
that is Andy no further explanation
required he's the only one besides you
that's just one character
oh we're proud baby but there is
explanation why Andy Andy is a kiss up
to Michael comes from a rich family
loves to randomly break out his song and
plays guitar and has some mild anger
okay this is interesting yeah no that
actually winds up the first one the
first step do you accept this comes from
a rich family Zach
I grew up fortunate I wouldn't say we
were super wealthy at you rich I grew up
fortunate well I wasn't I didn't grow up
in poverty but you know my my family
struggled for a little bit
mm-hmm you sounded like Andy to me
actually that's how I reworded it
originally said privilege I'm like that
sounds too strong
all right here it is
peaky [__] blinders peekaboo here's
my dick
that's Creed that's giving Creed
Ence
why did he say that he's drunk
oh okay what like but was there some
previous was that a callback to
something uh Ethan said peaky blinders
peekaboo my dick he was just on he was
doing some Creed [__]
freaky [__] blinders peek-a-boo
here's my dick
his hairline's too good speaker so right
here it's just him sucking up to you
could just stand below this the
billboard with a big audio system
absolutely I think that's a great idea I
don't I don't agree to do that why it's
good exposure it's a building yeah I
think that's a [__] great idea thank
you
Jack likes it yes you would I agree with
Ethan you would hear this what a
surprise you would hear this in like uh
all music is mariachi I agree with Ethan
I missed I I'm sorry Zach you used to
agree you used to back me up more I
missed that hold on can I back Zach up
go ahead he literally was just doing it
two days ago still backing you up how so
he just said I'm sorry I agree with
Ethan you and Dan were talking about
something it was the peaches and cream
thing oh yeah there yep I didn't want
that I didn't ask for peaches and creams
and Jordans and cam also agreed with the
peaches and cream
I said it grew on me I hated it at first
but now now I'm team peaches and cream
dude I always back you come on he does
yeah okay you used to ride harder
I mean I've I I grew up a little bit but
uh I thought the problem no that's a
problem I'll become a castratian cut my
testicles off so I can whatever it takes
man I just want the old Zack back okay
freaky [__] blinders peek-a-boo
here's my dick
hairline's too
good
yeah for like a minute
like five times yeah yeah oh here's the
anger hold on we didn't see the whole
thing you would hear this in like uh all
music is mariachi I agree with Ethan I'm
sorry
Zach let us know when you don't oh we
gotta consider the same for you that's
pretty far she's out I need to wash my
hands yeah
uh
they're both just down well we've lost
both of our hosts everyone
um so give us just a minute wait you
smelling it back there get the [__] out
of the seat what are you doing what are
you doing yes so I will smell this ass
to sit in the seat
[Music]
um
hold on a second let me just hit you
with this real quick
I hope this doesn't make you sound like
a douche
thank you Dan foreign
I extended that clip a little longer
because I just wanted my revenge let me
be clear what happened in that moment we
never talked about it Ela and Ethan
walked away because we sprayed the fart
spray and Ela goes AB can you go up
there where she walked away and I go up
there and sit and y'all just thought I
was trying to be a cloud Goblin when Ela
told me to go sit up there
it's insane just want to point that out
I was really uh hung up on that random
moment from two and a half years ago
except for you this whole PowerPoint was
just about that moment actually oh [__]
I'm sorry one sec I I've been thinking
about that yeah that's really been
weighing off he keeps me up at night I'm
actually I feel better now I feel better
already all right good next I wasn't
listening I'm sorry
ah
uh next slide okay now this is why this
was made okay let's here we go you're
hedging a little bit I see you're trying
to you're saying I'm Dwight but I'm also
Jim
and no Ryan I will point out Ryan is not
what no no
now how are you gonna beat the Ryan
charges you don't think there's any Ryan
going on here
I'll do you want better tell me how I am
Ryan
I saw receipts on the subreddit I don't
know I'm not the officeologist
let's see what you got
sexy [__] who looks into the
camera she's closed okay going to the
suicide forest Stephen come on
see what happens you don't know what you
find there we know anyway back to Kaylee
wow it's almost like you're doing it on
purpose let it play this is great I love
talking about this I have ideas for
clickbait can you guys ask
is Jim that's not fair that's not fair
to include that I know what you're
talking about isn't there an episode
where Ryan's trying to be the cool guy
is Toby's what huh I don't know there's
one where Ryan's like
I need someone who's more
more familiar with Ryan's uh Mo Zach
would know Zach's watched the show
there's a section on Ryan at the end
what are you getting from this Zach
like how do you mean
just tell them which way you want him to
ride
just yeah just say he's like Ryan just
tell him just tell Ethan that ab's like
Ryan yeah no he's like Ryan yeah thanks
bro
any anything for you Ethan you know I
got your back that was straight Creed
yeah what do you want I don't know what
going to the suicide for every time I
pause it it seems to restart yeah so
but then but we're talking right there's
that keemstar kidnapped my son and is
holding him Ransom oh that's what the
[__] that's true a b doesn't even have
pets
[Music]
um
or early flight I didn't realize you
were doing this so much
doing what doing this whole staring at
the camera thing I don't know what
you're talking about
so you're not doing that on purpose your
claim is
let it play who are you looking why are
you looking at the camera
is there somebody there that you're
trying to communicate to
okay I'll keep playing I already got the
door us
we live for this we nigh for this game
Evie looks upset you wouldn't you don't
want to be here maybe no no I just this
is my little office look at the camera I
do all the time he's doing the oh okay
so that's the self-report
cute little gym thing yeah you don't get
yourself Jay doesn't try to be Jim Jim
is Jim I also feel like this is a little
bit Stolen Valor because I've been doing
the [__] uh blue steel for a while
here we go don't worry I'll never make
that face
okay shots fired potentially I'd love
back at love
oh I'm just pointing out I don't want to
argue I would not steal his blue steel
all right let's keep it going to be Jim
helper
you know what I mean and you can't just
look at the camera for no reason it's
became it's become my thing the audience
likes it what is it why are you wearing
a tie
oh I don't know I just
it's not usually dress Are you seriously
coming in here trying to be like Jim
right now like give it a [__] break
all jokes aside that moment was so
[__] funny like slow as slowly as you
and Ila realized what I was doing
I knew you've been angling for this
though you've been trying to get in
people's heads you want so badly to be
Jim but I don't think the people are
buying it what does that sound like
look you already what who me Michael
Scott we have already established that
dude we're talking about you now
what character would do that
I don't know what you're trying I don't
know proceed okay talk about allegation
right this is this is yeah so now you're
owning the Dwight charges okay I love
how generous you are and how kind you
are
the multiple raises that you've given me
in just this year of working for you
I love
that you are a a great person a great
father
great husband I'm a great boss in the
sauce we got to do this again by the way
I love when AB starts complimenting me
Nobody Does it like him thank you thank
you I want to be on the receiving end
one day
they said nice things about you haven't
I I'm just kidding
I must have by now said at least one
nice thing yeah
I know I forgot I'm trying to make you
laugh I kind of got lost a little bit
I'll take the sincere compliments I need
it at least okay
I love that after the roast you
comforted me even though you called me a
shaky [__] I did well I was a little
bit of shaky [__] in a joke it was in
the episode it wasn't I think if I I was
just trying to be funny insulted because
you said I have tiny hands yeah
I think you have large hands no you
don't massive
no okay
let me think about that oh also also the
weight is always in competition with
Andy for Michael's love sound like two
people you know yeah yeah let me think
about it hold on let me think about it
hold on
also Dwight can be the office buzz kill
okay
well that's Dan's job I feel like but
let's see let's see you prove that
whoa
hello
damn what are you doing baby oh
you ready this is it I should see that
that is Dwight yeah I can see that being
Dwight
wait to this one but it's more like no
offense we have to keep working it's the
middle of the day
that's the the title oh my God [__] up
dude that's not even funny it's a joke
hey wait what happened not even hell man
you know
I made a mistake of thinking we were on
a comedy show and y'all were making
jokes about a title I made a joke that
if I really died and then all of a
sudden
we were in church I don't know everyone
was so you suggested that our friend
Bobby died and it's like
watching this now even in retrospect
makes me uncomfortable yeah it's a
little [__] weird
I mean there's some things you just
don't joke about
funny it's a joke Jesus Christ wait I
gotta go back this is awesome I turned
my head like I was allergic to the
reaction Bobby Lee is dying
that's the the title oh my God baby
[__] up dude that's not even funny
that was awesome
no he gets worse like Zach plays the
sound bite you need to leave everybody's
like what the [__] that's funny that's
good but sometimes I just don't and
maybe it's my fault I just don't and I
understand with you guys with the
audience too I just don't understand the
disconnect between like
doing a bit and people actually get it
worked up
I don't know doing a bit and what like
people like actually I'll let this play
out before I talk about it actually I
don't want to ruin this is not that I
can never understand you like and I mean
that genuinely because I saw a comment
in the a comment on our last episode it
was like
uh
can't I don't know if it was about cam
can Mumble something and I hear every
word but when AB speaks something like
no it was a video that we watched or or
a tweet that made no sense and you like
somehow to find some interpretation out
of it but maybe you can just ask you a
question you're like what the [__] no I
think there's something going on where
like
his voice he can't see your face face is
behind the screen I used to tilt my head
this way but then I would lean away from
the mic so I put the monitor so I don't
do that there's some kind of challenging
thing here logistically
it may be me I mumble a lot who's Roy it
says Trisha's Roy somebody said oh is
that Michael's crazy friend that's Pam's
EX
oh oh oh
I see the parallel that's messed up but
also interesting
okay
elbows
[Music]
thank you Gabby R uh she has some
messages she says a b uh soundsimp you
still have a lot to learn oh wow harsh
yeah no [__] you should have saved your
money
oh come on
how many of you went to the party
how many of you have a [__] brain
we are we okay okay I see the Dwight in
this in those ones who made this uh
compilation oh I'm trying to find it
it's called AV ruining the moment for
two minutes straight oh dude I gotta say
the the amount of work that people put
into this before you put it together is
pretty interesting oh yeah it's a
culmination of a whole community
makes me want by the way someone
mentioned Trish and I was just like
I'm not gonna go there because I'm not a
petty [__]
interesting I am a petty [__] wait what
am I talking about what are you talking
I did a whole PowerPoint because Dan and
Zack slighted me two years ago for five
seconds right
um what I what did you say I didn't hear
you he was joking about how he made this
whole thing to just bring up that that
one clip where we talk [__] on him
oh that where I couldn't uh sleep at
night from it yeah yeah exactly okay
what I was gonna say is um
Trisha made a new podcast with Colleen
Colleen
Ballinger Miranda Sings
I still don't know who that is you don't
wait seriously I mean I do now obviously
because you're doing it but I heard that
name so many times over the years and I
just never five years that's not my
world I don't [__] know
yeah five years ago she was like
the darling of YouTube she was like and
all the
yeah I definitely heard the name no
relation to the other things right
what other sayings Brian's seeing there
are other things Lily on the internet
yeah yeah no they're not they're a
different thing okay got it uh just to
remind you because her character was was
pretty annoying and that's fine
obviously it was for like a younger
audience of
obviously I'm not the demographic so I'm
not going to sit here and judge uh
uh but I'll just to give you an idea
react to Crazy tick tocks 50 million
views so shoot damn
I feel like you're gonna recognize me
hey guys it's me Miranda today I'm so
excited for my video because I'm
reacting to tick tocks not to be
confused with take tanks which are
Delight change this you know her yeah
that's Ryan asking me yeah no oh you've
never seen her okay so you guys seen
this you heard about this you know for I
have to admit for somebody that works
and makes a living on YouTube I just I
don't know YouTubers okay that's fair
enough everything I've learned about
YouTube I've learned from being on the
show was it and that's why it's
important we talk about this yeah okay
fine not as fun Tick Tock is this really
cool app where you can lip sync to
things excuse me I'm trying to run a
showered the competition I think anyway
my point was
she's in some actually a pretty wild
internet drama right now
uh it's pretty it's pretty juicy I mean
I don't know I on one hand I don't want
to talk about it because is it related
to Trisha or is it like separate from
that no it's not related to Trisha at
all make that clear they just have a
podcast together right that they just
started and ironically
Trisha is now not the controversial one
oh which is maybe feels good for her she
wants not to be the country she's kind
of gone clean in recent years right like
Trisha kind of stays out of this [__]
now so it's I I would say
I've been impressed with her
self-restraint since uh swing [__] say
what queen queen [__] Queen [__] just
say Amy do you know how to speak Spanish
perhaps he is wearing a mask today to be
fair a b yeah as a as a matter of
procedure just say things twice like
Jimmy Two Times like I'm gonna get the
papers yeah
yeah
but uh the this drama is pretty spicy
pretty interesting but
yeah was there so there's no like tying
this back into what we were someone
mentioned Trisha and it made me think
about it though okay no unreal it
totally unrelated
people want a PowerPoint on Colleen
see so my feeling on that is on one hand
I'm very interested in it
and if she didn't have a podcast with
Trisha I'd definitely be talking about
it but I also don't want it to look like
I'm being like a super petty [__]
because they just started a podcast
together yeah I understand because the
drama isn't Tricia's but because they're
co-hosts I wouldn't mention Trisha but
it would make it seem like I'm I'm
coming for her in a sense on her new
show it would be a potential embargo uh
violation
it's also not just drama it's like
accusations it's it's pretty serious I
mean from what I've seen it's quite
creepy yeah
the like she's the obnoxious lipstick
lady did something creepy she's so she
was talking with like really young kids
and confiding in them and asking them
sexual questions and stuff oh boy do I
have that right Olivia
yeah talking to them about sex super
weird man yeah it sucks you know what's
the weirdest when I went up there and I
covered Ela and I sat up there that one
day a lot of people online were like if
he does anything to get on camera and
all this [__] I'm like oh you
[__] I'm gonna make a
PowerPoint about this in two years bro
we should talk about that PowerPoint by
the way I don't understand
[Laughter]
sometimes I I'm like half-assed mom like
[__] just for the audience but I'm just
trying to say let's let's you're making
me seem crazy over here no no you're not
crazy I pause it and I focus with all my
money that's my fault you know what it
is I was raised around all yemenis when
I was younger and their dialect is to
speak very fast
so I just have this [__] up way of
speaking English so I apologize it's not
your fault it's not your fault it's my
fault it's my fault
oh
yeah but um it's not your fault
I don't know whatever let's continue
we're doing something here kabish
we finish this one okay next one whoa
oh this is an interesting one too far
Dwight always brings his estranged
cousin oh wow okay also it's because it
kind of looks like you I'm just gonna
say it
this guy looks like me
what's that got to do with anything oh
that's what do you think Moe's looks
like Ethan that's isn't that Michael
sure yeah he's like he's like the head
writer of the show that guy King
it's not funny
um
also I forgot to mention that uh
the white always says
facts or fact and I always give you
facts oh he goes fact yeah yeah and then
he says the fact I'm just spitting facts
you know
all right so so that's it okay now yeah
that's it I feel that the a b analysis
we need to take a second look at the
evidence from the perspective of you
being Ryan that's all I'm saying the
last slide is about Ryan but
I don't know okay well let's come back
to it here is uh oh you see so here is
Ryan trying to do the gym thing
he's trying to do the gym thing
but it's not genuine he's in that's what
you do yeah you're not like genuinely
looking at the camera you're forcing it
you're and you even said oh I'm trying
to do the gym thing yeah Kim that's
never [__] forgive you for sending
that that's a good fine cam no but he's
not a discovery he has a good point I
mean if we're gonna in the interest of
Truth yeah no I got you I got you you
know interesting look at this one
especially I don't even watch the show
I'm sorry baby
you sold them out
filled them up the river let's continue
on I don't know I'm more sold on the
Dwight thing so
yeah no okay we'll talk about at the end
but um this is love is the other
personal side [__] is that love is the
other person besides Gila that I had a
problem with wait this guy was like
briefly in a few others right okay but
listen listen to who he was he was
Dwight 2.0 he was like a more efficient
Dwight he was like a younger he was more
like tech savvy
um okay I was suggesting this who the
[__] is that though he was in like two
episodes
I was in the later Seasons
oh that's probably why okay Oscar was
there the whole time I think you're just
mad because you have to share Oscar me
too were those worth watching when
Michael left because I stopped watching
too only the last episode
just the last one there's a there's a
yeah there's a special he also uh made
love to uh Jan as well
who did the Clark did there you go love
you what
that character when did that happen he
[__] all right let's move on
do you want me to read this are you yeah
I'm sorry love I I really really you
could ask everyone else I literally sat
everyone down and was like who who is
love who the [__] who the [__] is Uncle
love I need help with love ABY wrote I
am not sure I am sorry love FICA for
life I love you love
who could love me in the office yeah
maybe the audience knows or
uh see some Creeds I don't know if
that's right agreed in the sense that
you're kind of just sometimes you're
just there
like sometimes they just cut the Creed
you just forget he's there I don't mean
that with peace and love I'm just trying
to you know yeah yeah
uh yeah I'm not really sure I couldn't
tell I couldn't tell you not for not for
long though once you move here that that
won't be all right that's true that's
true it's just about
did you just get up and leave
in the middle of his own presentation
he quit love is the prince sir you were
getting me a drink
you're getting me chairman why are you
oh that's super old
thanks bro
I already got one thank you so much
though no problem right of the year it's
a good man that AB
by a lot of people saying Aaron
no that's Aaron because Aaron well Aaron
and
Toby
what's his name the doo-wop guy Andy
because Aaron and Andy have a romantic
relationship what does that mean for our
analysis
I think you have to kind of disconnect
the yeah
okay get stuck real quick yeah I don't
know I I don't know about the uh
the Aaron I mean I do like Aaron as a
character but she also she wasn't she
like sleeping with her brother or
something that was real life we gotta we
gotta not worry about the real life uh
no that was an episode
two was she lives with her brother and
they take baths together and [__] they
were they were uh foster kids together
they weren't like blood but there was
some weird weird [__] going on okay but
something in real life with her too
wasn't she love is Phyllis part of a
cult or something
what about Kevin
you too smart for uh yeah half these
characters you're mentioning that's the
thing
love what about Phyllis I don't I'm just
a guy I'm just love maybe he's just love
okay we tried that
I don't know he's Robert California
because some days get a
he's got a house yeah
All Right Moving On
Sam is Pam and Angela
okay that's a that's a great combo I
mean
strong why Pam for Sam Sam is talented
artist she's creative and hardworking
Sam Temple shop.com
wow
compelling stuff okay got it also why
Angela she loves her oh also she's in an
office romance I forgot to mention that
for Pam
um why Angela she loves her cats and
also
you please play this that's good that's
good you got her on that one
she's [__] me over a few times by like
being visibly upset and then people get
even more angry at me she does that to
me back what the [__] bro oh
[Music]
yeah she does she's done that a few
times I think she's she's trying to
steal my stick we need it we need to I
need to bring her up here well point out
Sam does not control when the camera
flips to her and she's not looking at
the camera right so
okay that's good I I like that yeah why
did you do that
okay wait is that it's a joke
uh next all right now now we're mixing
shows we're getting three characters
I didn't want to do this I know I'm
scared this I was scared about this one
Creed and Phyllis so originally free
things guy originally Creed and fellas
because Creed you know he's kind of like
Joker brain and you know randomly knows
so much stuff like cam knows a lot about
a lot of random stuff very smart guy uh
Phyllis office sweetheart cam sweetheart
but uh Steve Harrington because the
office sweetheart
he's a little loony isn't she Zack
what's your take she's the office
sweetheart don't say she's the office
sweetheart she she is a loving person I
would say Okay
um but I wouldn't say sweetheart no Zach
I loved your expertise on the matter it
was kind of a circle you know but uh
sometimes you just gotta roll with it
like like the best for a thousand bucks
I feel like that's sweetheart material
I feel like the money I'm definitely
Looney I'll take that all right let's
let's unpack this
why Steve
go ahead
uh so essentially what I just said
but I do find this rather interesting
because cam may be the nicest dude I
know but when we were talking about that
stranger things character who are we
very possessive over Steve very
possessive interesting and if you'll
remember the audience gave him what he
wanted too it's just because I want to
remember the outfit there was no there
was no stopping him there was no
stopping him okay no stop him you can
see even right now you're you're just
watching the clip you're telling him to
calm down he's like now [__] that I'm
Steve all right I was told that Olivia
and I would be dressed up as
Steve Harrington and who the hell told
you that Olivia let's look angry oh wait
just wait for it tell me this Ian has an
issue okay
go ahead not the information to talk yet
what the hell is going on okay so now
cam you made it sound pretty innocent
you're just saying well I was I was
given a role and I was enthused to take
on that role and then Ian for whatever
reason
you tell us what happened okay we had a
light-hearted conversation see look he's
so integrated please try not to wake him
up write him up citations
we are trying to resolve conflict here
if you could avoid man is this a Steve
though thing can we stay it is not but
you mediating the situation is very
Michael Scott okay but
let it play he gets more Steam on Ian
please during the negotiation okay
we were having a conversation about
which personal office is which character
from stranger things and I was given
Steve Harrington right out there that
was not what happened
those Scoops Ahoy Olivia conversation
came way later no hello guys guys cam
you gotta let Ian speak
okay and then and then you can rebut
unplug it unplug that it's important
it's important during HR uh conflict
resolution it's called radical listening
Cameron you need to just listen to what
he's saying and then take the time to
respond afterwards great so
I put Ford in a light-hearted jovial way
that Cameron if he were stranger things
character
would be
one of the buyers boys
I just find that amazing because cam is
the nicest guy I know but
right but how so is this related in
anything yeah Steve Harrington and he
always will be right but how is that
related to our PowerPoint ask him not me
he didn't make the PowerPoint I would
ask him okay well I answered because
he's Steve Harrington he always will be
I'll take it I'm Steve Harrington and I
always will be right but it's about the
office
I never finished the office is Steve
Harrington in the office did I mess that
up now
he makes the meme
interesting
so we're just mixing IPS now willy-nilly
it happens I feel like this kind of
solely is the Integrity of the whole
presentation you would say they wouldn't
shoot Toby yeah well I mean I'm sorry or
are you being uh up to this point you
know I was on board but now everything's
in question why are we in stranger
things Multiverse why are we not upside
down upside down
the only thing upside down is this
presentation it's flipped okay chill out
okay chill out wait wait wait wait can
we go back a sec
okay if we're if I'm gonna continue to
be possessive of a character
why didn't I get Pam if Sam got
pam pam for being creative and artsy
okay artsy stuff this is this is another
thing too he was starting to get a
little bit worked up about not being Pam
because she's the artist but I yeah I'm
an artist too I know but I initially
initially what it was is that Pam was
three other people and and Jim's three
other people right now too
sorry I was about to ban someone uh
yeah if you wanted you're Pam dude I'm
Pam dude Pam has more than just artistic
that's all I know about Pam I'll take it
[Music]
Sam he might be more Pam than Sam
although at the same time Sam is more
multiple people can be multiple
characters you know apparently we're all
just a whole ton of people out
everyone's gym everyone's everyone
everyone's the main character here
everybody's everybody's cool
everybody's the protagonist so here's
Olivia
is Kelly and Aaron mixed correct okay
okay
that one
that one that makes so much sense yeah
Olivia's Aaron yeah I'm feeling that
Kelly's character in the office yeah
Kelly has also got the scoop on the
drama and um right all that fun stuff
right and I know exactly where this is
beautiful
Timeless Renaissance Fair give it up for
the ren Fair everyone
hillywood's so good
okay
go ahead
uh however Olivia is more Kelly she's
all about the Tea celebrity gossip great
actress it can be dramatic sometimes
okay but I'm here today not to prove
that I'm crazy but to prove that I am
right and she's gonna prove she's not
crazy by showing us her 90 page
PowerPoint about my drama I'm saying I'm
not here to prove that I'm crazy I'm
here to prove that I'm right and if in
that it proves that I'm crazy we can
have the conversation all right that's
crazy you stay married and Loud too also
but this isn't about you let's talk
parasocial relationships for a minute
by the way I'm here transformative
moment in show history
the Selena Gomez drama explanation was
was a powerful was a powerful moment it
was it was yeah and also share real
quick I just want to point out because
obviously some of these are different
lengths but uh
I literally finished this five minutes
before we went live I did not sleep
so all those people saying Alby you're
welcome God bless okay I think you did a
wonderful job thank you for the point
now thank you for for putting in I'm
here today not
uh okay now we're getting Aaron again
and Pam
Aaron and Pam
wait are those oh right now she's Aaron
got it and Kelly all right all right she
is and then Lena's Aaron and Pam
I see it
I see it you want to read it uh Lena's
Aaron for similar reasons to Olivia
Springs Immaculate Vibes to the office
true both of them together are like
fireworks
yeah I love that
oh I know you're here
do the thing do the thing to each other
there it is
girl
okay
go ahead okay uh although I believe
she's more like Pam than uh Aaron speak
partially it's because she's not afraid
to take risks or challenge herself like
when Pam walked through the hot coal
when none of the other co-workers would
the same way Lena took the Hot Chip
also uh because her marriage started
with an office relationship that's when
we were waiting because your gym well
Lena oh you guys don't believe anyway I
see this Lena does she's challenges
herself and she's like she goes Joker
brain like in the the way that you never
expect you want to know what her
nickname was at the restaurant what
No No One's Gonna believe it I'll give
you a hint okay
that's it that was my hand what was your
hint the [__] are you talking about just
say it Pam and Jim uh they called you
guys Pam and Jim they did all right and
that's why I take this personally and
Lena who started the nicknames was it a
b no it wasn't
[Laughter]
sorry yeah all of our co-workers okay
well I'm glad you were here to clear
that up okay
that definitely would have been the
narrative
go ahead please
uh but more importantly it's a fact that
her relationship with Ethan is scary
identical to Michael and Pam's minus any
of the creepy [__]
is Michael creepy on Pam no there's only
maybe a few times a couple times enough
for occasion no you're not creepy but I
agree with this
you do is the fact that her relationship
with Ethan is scary identical to Michael
and Pam's minus the creep is up thank
you for uh making that exception I
appreciate that
I feel like that there is pretty
wholesome there's like one point when
his his girlfriend left him and he tried
to kiss Pam and she made him drive home
in the back seat
I do remember that yeah there was just
one oh that was brutal
I totally forgot about that
okay so then let's spell it out like
when when the drove Ethan at the
hospital late at night because he had
pesto poop
that did happen
yeah Friday night I I couldn't
go like five minutes without [__]
and I was getting super dehydrated I
kept I was just drinking water drinking
water and then I started feeling super
nauseous so my body wouldn't
um take the liquid
and my stomach just started getting so
full and then I puked
a ton of liquid out and that's when I
got really into trouble because my body
got super dehydrated I started like
shaking my heart rate was elevated
anyway Lena God bless her took us took
me to the uh to the Urgent Care you know
oh boy
yeah it was just me Ela and the kids and
whatever so what what do you think about
this analogy yeah Friday night you were
quick to agree yeah no I I agree in
terms of like Pam's relationship to
Michael I would be Pam in that sense
in what sense in the relate the in her
relation to Michael yeah I'm gonna have
to be the assistant okay
I'm trying to force you to say something
I'm not humiliating about me
like share a story no whatever I'll
watch this Eddie pulled down his pants
and showed you his butt no like no he
didn't she didn't know that there was a
hole in it I just want to explain real
quick I completely understood this story
and then I was like oh [__] and I was
ready I was trying to cover for you
because I I I started to realize that I
misunderstood Lena but then you just
ended up saying it anyways but I thought
she was she told me Teddy walked in on
you or she walked in on Teddy as you
guys are preparing for this Teddy fresh
shoot but I don't I'll I okay I don't
know what you're talking about so I'll
just watch okay hold down his pants and
showed you his butt no like no he didn't
she didn't know that there was a hole in
it and he turned around and she saw yeah
yeah what my ass
your son's ass
wait when did my mother there was no
hole in my son's pants no just Ethan
wait I'm so confused no no I'm confused
I thought Theo had over one
okay maybe I'm wrong then I'm confused
dude you you had to know that my abs
coming out with my ass out
when did we did the photo shoot yeah
yeah I didn't know though because I know
you gave everyone a warning but I was
with Theodore the whole time I was kind
of watching him because I was like
everybody listen up I'm about to show my
ass I wasn't down there look away
I just walked in I'm like oh oh okay
you know who else Pam walked in on
Michael I
burning the shorts outside
okay
well sorry about that oh no no worries I
mean I did post a picture on Instagram
for the whole everybody but
it's different being face to face with
it
and I I didn't know what's happening at
that time just Theodore wanted to see
you so I took him into that room and we
were like oh
so yeah
all right get the apology Podium out I
swear to God I was like everybody
my ass is out Now's the Time I said
disclaimer guys everybody knew what was
happening
now I've sexually assaulted Lina
yeah we just did harassment training the
other day Ethan what the hell yeah we
didn't do that do that I literally was I
couldn't have disclosed it more
right and I saw
you were in the backyard burning the
shorts too so I knew it was coming but I
didn't know what's going on at that
moment God so you came out and saw my
fat ass
well it's about to be all over Twitter
apparently yeah yeah it is it's going to
go up on it a whole lot of other people
okay Eddie pulled down his pants I see
that
oh Jimmy Lee okay this is good I like
this Jamie Lee's Todd packer
I like that okay and then this is
Ryan is not a baby
and I didn't have time to really put an
explanation but
I'll just say simply put Michael is
obsessed with Ryan
I always remember for Ryan Ryan can't
stand Michael
which does not follow our Dynamic
whatsoever well they chant their Dynamic
changed later in the no right he still
tried to ride for him no he seemed
I don't know okay also Ryan treats his
significant other like [__]
right
which you don't definitely don't okay
there it is guys
AB is not Ryan he is
which nobody else got the nod Jim
and there it is
I would say the most compelling one
really is Michael Scott and me there was
a lot of receipts there man yeah it took
a lot of time there was just a lot of
receipts there
but okay Abby good job beautiful
I I feel like Dan is more like a mix of
creed
um uh
uh Jim Andy Dwight and Aaron if you
could combine all those characters
and also a little bit of John Luke
Picard
I was gonna say uh
I was gonna say Jonathan Byers Maybe
they're all different flavors you're
kind of like 11. if you took 11 and then
combined it with Pam Jim Aaron Dwight
freaking epic and I'm also the doctor
from Doctor Who bro and Iron Man
all right that was fun thank you guys
thank you AB
s my pleasure thank you everybody
there it is there it is
oh
there it is oh oh there it is there it
is oh so I guess we have um we have to
talk about this twitch drama pretty
juice pretty juice
you have to talk about
the Boomer comedian who hates sumers was
that did that yield anything good
it's pretty annoying right
who dug into that one it was like me it
was like that was the spiciest line I
saw a clip of her on tick tock
and I was like man she's annoying he
doesn't know her special was uh about
all different Generations so she talked
about all of them and that was her take
on Zoomers okay just that like we have a
hard time with a paper map and stuff
this was the joke I saw and I was like
what the hell he doesn't know how to
write a check
they don't know how to address an
envelope they don't know how to read
cursive yeah well that shit's for old
people we don't need to do that [__]
anymore dummy see I don't know why I'm
getting defensive is that the
no [__] well listen how to read a paper
map
they can't get anywhere unless there's a
GPS map on their phone
all I'm saying is that gen Z takes over
the world it's gonna be
people okay and then I don't know what
the [__] this is but I don't like it
then this guy responds and it gets weird
here I'll play this right like I saw
someone do at it just the first part so
I clicked through
to find the original and it's includes
this guy for some reason and it's very
bizarre be able to know how to read your
messed up curse of handwriting but at
least I know how to get in and out of
self-checkout without spending 20
minutes there oh also who the hell got a
paper map in 2023
this ain't got damn Yogi Bear this ain't
the goddamn 1800s what are you Lewis and
Clark who the hell has a paper map at
the ready
I got a challenge for the Boomers
go a whole year being tech savvy
and let's see how that works for you yo
just first let me help you with you
the Zoomers are hitting back watch the
[__] out Boomers that's my people dude
that's your boy right there oh yeah bro
this comes from bone Fork by the way
it's me uh in Vatican City
accepting the Forgiveness of his
Holiness the Pope
so good very sweet
Pope Philip the first I guess
second
third I don't know
Roman Atwood actually came out with some
really spicy wild transphobic clip this
one's pretty fun actually
in the sense that first of all I haven't
heard that name in a long time you guys
remember Roman Atwood
he was like besties with Fouseytube and
he used to do really horrible pranks he
was one of the first pranks in the hood
guys actually I see and uh then he
started making family content
which is about to be the great like
really popular for a minute but it was
always super phony because I know this
guy doesn't he's not a wholesome guy you
know what I mean like I know that about
him the pranks in the hood guy yeah
exactly yeah probably not but I used to
watch him daily
every day so what'd you think about that
it sounds it looks like the Vlogs are
done
the Vlogs were dumb yeah he's doing his
podcast now which he's saying I
mentioned this before he said something
really sassy on his podcast
like a year ago too about uh I don't I
think abortions and I was like what the
[__] he's like very conservative try to
pull that up yeah I'll try to find it
but he's very yeah that's the part that
you didn't see during the vlogs well so
he's getting in to a fair bit of trouble
right now moving out for like the most
out of pocket I cannot believe how I
touch people still are on like trans
[__]
they open their mouth and it's just like
wow the [__] here it is um
these old school YouTuber if you know
him you know him if you don't you don't
all right guys 15 million subscribers he
was huge well back like I don't know
five years ago he was posting a family
Vlog every day and was getting like a
million views every day maybe more
sometimes more
so he was definitely crushing it man he
was the one that gave it tally his
comeback interview
after he yeah and and thank God for that
yeah nobody's more deserving of a second
chance than him oh he's converted to
church of Latter-day Saints that's
Mormons right yes who converts to
Mormonism like a lot of people the only
reason you should be a Mormon is because
your ass was born isn't it the if you
marry into it you convert
dude like if your partner
why why would you convert into that
um
well I don't know
good uh good networking they are they
are really good at networking yeah it's
true those guys it's a business decision
um I once uh during a religion class we
had to go to a a church from a religion
we hadn't previously uh been to and I
went to a church of Latter-day Saints
and the bread they cut up Wonder Bread
like white bread and then for the wine
it was water just like little cups of
water and then the the church texted me
for a very long time after that saying
Hey Olivia you want to come by uh
they're Swoosh
yeah I tell you bro those those Mormons
are pretty wild I'll be honest nice
people but wild so nice they're so nice
but that's kind of what makes them so
weird
great uh great musicals too
every Mormon I ever met I've said this
before
there's quite a few I knew in high
school
they could they're the most friendliest
people you can ever imagine
I'll never forget one conversation I had
this was a dude I was very friendly with
he was super nice
and I was curious about his religion
because I didn't know a lot about
Mormonism I said do you think me as a
Jewish person I'm going to hell
and he said well
he's like well yeah
and I was like whoa that's crazy
and just it's hard to reconcile because
he's like so sweet but also like you're
gonna [__] perish and hellfire for
eternity that's all
that's all Christians well maybe not all
I'm sure there's some denominations that
think there's a lot there's a lot that
share that opinion you're right
it's just a wild like also by the way
study shows Mormons uh are the fastest
growing religious group in the U.S so to
ask you a question about who is uh
converting to Mormonism A lot of people
evidently as a fan of the Real
Housewives of Salt Lake City those
Mormons are oh
Wild
whenever we talk about burning the witch
you know the era where we used to burn
the witch right yeah that area never
really stopped the type of witch we was
burning changed and the nature of
burning also changed what about what
about a change who's the witch
men
wow that's buddy that's what he's in men
it is so anyway Roman Atwood is getting
a ton of backlash for his May 31st
episode that was a week ago with his
wife Brittany on the topic of the Bud
Light controversy with Dylan Mulvaney uh
you can you can anticipate a really
enlightened take here from Roman Atwood
you should put up the uh disclaimer that
we disagree with him
uh uh let me find that oh right I just
look stupid
um here I got this disclaimer
uh that's not the one we got this uh
trying to cry challenge
uh uh we got we got this bang on all
cylinders here folks
I found that clip I was looking for by
the way drop it drop it it was about
them kind of admitting to belting their
kids oh let me hear that yeah I found
that while just watching their podcast
they're kind of keeping it kind of
always catch me and they give you which
is super interesting because their whole
shtick is like happy family we're the
ant would family let's freaking go
because they're keeping it kind of like
it's disgusting though okay so right
here at one minute 24 seconds yeah okay
my father used a belt on me yeah now you
go to jail for that
yeah it's like I'm going to jail
that's kind of like an admission right
yeah yeah one time we had our uh I mean
or do you think it's a joke no I think I
could say it's an admission
all right is that it
well they talk keep talking about it but
I think that isn't that kind of like
admitting your business yeah I think so
no but it's like I'm going to jail oh
Brit he's talking about his wife yeah
okay I misunderstanding I could I could
get you a couple loops but you would
always catch me you had it easy though
was that his dad father used to build on
me yeah now you go to jail for that it's
[__] disgusting no but yeah it's like
I'm going to jail
I mean it's still more common than you
probably think at least here I can't
speak yeah but in the states
more accepted yeah I mean dude literally
when I was a kid people were beating
their kids yeah I mean lots of my
friends growing up I feel like that's
that's like a relatively new
train of thought that you shouldn't hit
your kids yep pretty wild but that's
what it is
um so I think I'm realizing that that
disclaimer is in leftovers uh like
that's where we normally sweet
Perkins that show the leftovers which is
a great show by the way thank you I like
that thank you Matt I'm a lot so yeah as
Dan cues that up let me know when you've
got it and we'll get to our boy Roman
Atwood who's fully enlightened
on board with modern thinking
[Music]
Dan is queuing up the overlay that says
we fully disagree with this dumbass
idiot
open
[Music]
UMass idiot importing the image
with this
dumb ass idiot
yeah
we
fully disagree with this dumb ass idiot
idiot idiot
and
um
[Music]
drum roll
hey all right we got it thank you
they used
a man
trying to be a female to promote beer
right an American All-American if you're
trigger warning this is like the most
ignorant [__] I've heard about trans
people in like a decade
worse than Matt Walsh
well
in the sense I think Matt Walsh is
trying to be it's probably worse this
man's being genuine in this moment I
don't even think Matt Wilson Jimmy he
just you know what I mean okay it's the
ignorance I guess oh man trying to be a
female to promote beer right an American
All-American if you're gonna use a
female why not use a female that was
born a female that's capable of birthing
children
um that wasn't the point of the dude
there's plenty of women who who have
probably deals with Budweiser yeah it's
actually yeah I don't think that's a
non-exclusive they don't they don't
disqualify each other trying to be a
female but this whole notion of it's
she's he
she's just trying to be a female
it's crazy to promote beer right an
American All-American if you're gonna
use a female why not use a female that
was born a female that's capable of
birthing children and raising them how
the [__] does that have to do with it
relevant to the Budweiser commercial
I'll tell you what man that ain't no
female
I'm drinking this Bud Light and no more
how about dealing with a period every
single month why not just give a woman
that position but light would Thrive if
they did that so what's the agenda why
I'm confused smile more unless you're
trans yeah
he goes he's doing the trans women are
doing Stolen Valor I guess from men
because they don't have a period
what if they were shooting that
commercial
and suddenly we needed
we needed a baby
right then and there what would we do
yeah without
like what is his point I don't
understand the point so he he I think he
doesn't think that trans uh do you think
is a real thing he thinks the
opportunity is being taken away from
somebody that's a biological woman right
by but the opportunity is
the Outreach to the LGBT community right
so that is the opportunity and that's
why he I and again there are lots of
women I'm sure with deals with beer
companies this is not one of those
things
I I think his his thesis seems to be
that
trans people are not real it's part of
an agenda and why are you rewarding this
guy who's pretending to be a woman
to promote beer right an American
All-American if you're gonna use a
female why not use a female that was
born a female that's capable of birthing
children and raising them
um how about dealing with a period every
single month why not just give a woman
that position right but light would
Thrive if they did that so what's the
agenda Bud Light with Thrive if they
only would
sponsor a woman if only there was a
woman in a Bud Lightroom
they would be thriving but yet I wonder
why yeah this just happened like two
days ago or a week ago I think how long
it's like three months ago this [__]
Bud Light thing happened they probably
moved on to Target yeah you're way
behind man we need to be talking are we
talking about Bud Light Target's
grooming yeah
um
it's just it's so remarkably ignorant
that people are still saying this [__]
I'm confused by that why is Woman of the
Year not a not a biological One Forever
Woman of the Year who's woman of the
year
yeah this was from May 31st a week ago
what one who's woman of the year and
also just like no matter what the answer
to that is
because the answer is most likely you
know it's some magazine well it's like
who cares Caitlyn Jenner was woman of
the year like a decade is that what they
were talking about I can't think of any
other woman of the year it's just like
do we take that seriously do we do we
care years ago it was one time can
anybody name any other woman of the year
who's the most recent woman how many
trans women have been named woman of the
year
I would be pissed that's weird well
guess what we're not I'm not
you're good you're just you're slapped
you're slipped I'll tell you what man if
I was a woman I'd be pissed off because
that could have been my money
this Dylan Mulvaney
you stealing my money
he's so dumb I mean you could just see
his face he looks like a cartoon
character
he's got like kind of a Gumby ass
looking face
I would be so pissed like I've seen you
sound pissed now and you're not a woman
people comparing like
um
some of the the men women transgender
men women I'm getting it all backwards
to like doing blackface right is it like
literally making fun of women you've
heard that
I've never heard that that's pretty
crazy that's a new one that's a new one
to me that's [__] wild ignorant takes
I've ever heard of my life so the
existence of trans women
on its face
is an assault should be an insult an
attack on women everywhere
because
they're parroting women by I don't know
the goal is to make fun of women
I guess that's what it is that's what
GPT doesn't have that info uh here's the
thumbnail and title of this episode
enter at your own risk Christopher Mr
Beast Bud Light sells plummet and Target
oh they hit them all transphobia super
episode I see who's watching this like
this is the most UN insightful proudly
ignorant unnuanced dumb [__] podcast
ever no I'll tell you why it's even
worse who's watching that it's his old
fans his the young kids bro below below
18 100 I bet they're
seriously yeah yeah because
what adults gonna stumble upon this guy
and like him it's it has to be yeah what
kid would watch this this is so much
yeah no no I I mean I mean like kids
will stumble in because his normal
videos he's doing like videos with the
old like Vlog members that he did before
so people are going to come back and
like watching hopefully most people see
that he's a [__] piece of [__] he's
just an alien a lot of kids are
definitely going to watch that and like
just listen to him 100 being trans is
like doing blackface that's awesome I
would be pissed
I would be so pissed like I've seen
people comparing like
um
some of the the men women transgender
men women I'm getting it all backwards
to like doing blackface right is it like
literally making fun of women dude you
are so [__] dumb
and they're getting their parts and
they're getting their roles and they're
getting they're beating them in sports
what the [__] this man thinks there's an
army of trans women taking leading roles
that's just Shredder a Charged Alfredo
he's taking they're taking the rules
they're taking the jobs they're taking
our men
they're taking our
random one-off Bud Light they're taking
our Bud Light sponsorship like what the
trans women are invading
nothing left for the real women I just
love the throwing out there they're
stealing the women of the year like
again it's like I looked at like woman
of the year 2022 right last year I mean
USA Today names A Woman of the Year Time
magazine that should have gone too his
world Athletics glamor billboard like it
that's just that doesn't mean anything
it's just like a meaningless it's it's
like
it's like the steamies that we do it's
like who [__] cares like there's no
like Prestige behind it at all so who
gives a [__] and like you said it was
once like 10 years ago you deserved all
of them the woman of the Year Awards
it's just who cares I wonder if I want
to be here
I wonder if he's at a point of
irrelevance that he's just like time to
grift no I think he genuinely I don't
think he I think no I think he believes
that but I think he's like well if if
you go to the channel I think he does a
lot of this [__] well he's he has
suppressed those things these like kind
of ideas
he never talked about it now I think
he's too comfortable almost I think he's
gone oh yeah that's for sure yeah
although maybe this is an opportunity of
uh dispelling some ignorance on his part
yeah bro that's a topic that just I
can't figure out I can't figure it out
yeah well
you gotta try a little bit
I can't but nothing happens
awesome right pretty wild there it is
Roman Atwood's smile more people
trying to think
people are saying I care about the
steamies okay I didn't mean to disparage
the steamies I'm I'm sorry well one we
got to do women of the year now we
should do it give it to a trans woman
but I mean even our audience can admit
it's like if let's say silly let's say
we had women of the year
this year and we gave it to Jeff
whittick and then and then 10 years from
now you're bringing it up on a podcast
about how [__] up that was a decade
later that's that's tell you what man
that Jeff whittak one woman of the year
I'd be pissed okay they taken away our
jobs it's like one one it happened once
forever ago and two who cares who won
this random award I don't know oh oh
this is great Roman Atwood smile more
put out a pride merge
just this year
this man I will point out that there is
no uh
no trans flag on there
right I guess that's yeah
but I mean it's a pride flag
do we need the do is that the new Italy
I feel like I mean after seeing that
clip it feels intentional to to Omit
that does it not pride is not a virtue
it seems like it's just trying to
[__] make money yeah yeah uh
Community it's kind of even more
Shameless it's so [__] crazy it's
awesome what's with these cups too
what's the relation there GQ
lead fuel yeah yeah
you'd have to be psychotic to drink that
garbage
you're just from 2015.
oh it is okay rip
yeah so that's that's great they've gone
we've gone backwards so we're regressing
yeah we love that uh Team YouTube
responded they said hey so sorry you're
still experiencing this could you tell
us more about what you're seeing
feel free to so that this means they
have this is what they told me a Week
Ago picture [__] is flipped just like I
don't know what to tell these people
map closes when it happens it happens to
everyone watching on the app also my
notifications are working so sorry your
experiences mind sharing this in our
feedback tool I don't know how other
ways to tell you guys this
yesterday they said we're aware of it
oh um yo Terry Joe for Woman of the Year
someone said that's so true
that's so true or maybe maybe the woman
of the year which should be Roman Atwood
Maybe
I think Roman would love that
you should do that women We Are Men
so I don't know I don't know what to
tell them they they can't they don't
know what's happening
what screenshot can we send you it just
says there's an error and the app closed
well if you can provide them any
information please do here
because uh
this isn't getting fixed
so weird am I the only are we the only
people with this problem how would they
not part of it I wonder if it's
I hope that Mike didn't pick my voice up
cracking no nobody heard that no no no
no
um I wonder if it's because Apple's
updating its software if it has anything
to do with it their conference that
they're doing right now they just talked
about iOS 17 so I wonder if it has
something to do with that you mean
people need to update their iOS
or
I'm not sure I've seen people say say
update your app I don't know if that's
worked for anyone
I don't know
you know what this twitch it doesn't I
don't really care about it what happened
what is switch doing they said didn't
they already backtrack it love
yeah they backtrack pretty hard yeah but
they didn't really backtrack fully they
didn't like say like sorry we're wrong
but you're kind of like uh
we we misrepresented what we meant which
is I'm curious what you think because
here look look at these guidelines
this is what I'm showing now yeah open
the images okay I'll tell you this
burned in audio ads burned in display as
burned in video ads are not allowed that
[__] has never been allowed on YouTube
not allowed on YouTube and I 100 get
that right selling ads on the videos now
you can't just burn in your own ads now
look at the images
okay so let's see Logan's logos on
stream
over there's limited three percent of
screen size
and that format it's that's permitted so
that is permitted with limitation so
logos on stream how do you say three
this seems like bigger than three
percent I think like three percent is
three percent is very very small like
can you let's let's make cam you can do
this let's make a a
rectangular screen and then show me what
three percent of the pixels are five
percent means everything you just make
it as an overlay and then I can throw it
up yeah because I can do exactly three
percent actually wait hold on okay this
here
one sec this black dot is three percent
of a hundred percent of them this this
seems needlessly restrictive the three
percent that seems stupid to me
seems a little goofy right so but let's
see yeah so here's three percent this is
what I had a feeling they making it look
uh reasonable but this is insane you
can't you're not gonna even read that
what the [__] is it very very tiny like
this this is like
that's like ten percent well
maybe like seven eight yeah something a
lot more if it was this size it'd be a
lot more reasonable but look at this
[__]
what the [__] three percent very small
five percent that's crazy
thank you to our sponsor if you guys
could zoom right in there on the three
percent there it says uh Verizon
so that's insane
uh and then they say formats limiter are
not allowed and burned ads I get that I
100 understand but I'm curious that has
never been enforced on YouTube really
right yes it is I got a video removed
for that [__] yeah no burned in is
literally when you make a when they send
you a commercial
and you put it in your video but I think
what about you talk about burning the
wish when have you ever seen that news
news channels like uh CNN between [__]
they they roll an ad surely that's like
pretty common right I don't know CNN
does not roll their ads on YouTube and
if you're seeing that that's an illegal
stream that's somebody else that's just
hijacking the uh yeah because a lot of
support stuff a lot of esport between
the breaks or between rounds they roll
ads on almost all Esports tournaments
that's different on the Live Crew and
that's probably I mean that's gonna ruin
Esports yeah tournament they may have
had an exception for those companies I
don't see those as being the same a
burned in ad is when you make a deal
with a brand and they say play this
commercial and you burn it into your
video that's what it is if if you're
watching an event and there's sponsors
to the event I don't see that as burned
in
well they definitely use burned in ads
on esport tournaments and stuff I've
never seen it I've never seen a burn Dad
in YouTube
I did a a sponsor with a mattress
company and we shot it ourselves and
stuff and I got the whole [__] video
removed it was crazy
yeah insert burned in display ads uh
burned and well okay display ads
streamers may not insert display or
banner ads
yeah so that one seems pretty ridiculous
that's very Broad in the sense that like
a lower third is that a banner that's I
mean their picture of it sure looks like
a lower third I mean so yeah
this is like just horribly unclear yeah
but the three percent thing is like a
joke did you all even think about this
before you put the statement out like
come on three percent
five percent
by the way the embargo's pretty much
lifted I'll have you know it takes up
five percent five percent
five percent
means everything
so I guess everybody is uh rightfully
upset about that people got all very up
in arms about it
they also said have to disclose branded
content oh that's not fair
you're telling me they have to disclose
their brand deals you mean be compliant
with the law that's been in place for
like 10 years yeah that one's not that
one doesn't seem like too much to ask
creators cannot promote hateful products
or Services illegal products or services
certain gambling products weapons
Financial Services
medical products and political content
was this all you allowed before
no I think I think they're just
reiterating the parts of the policy that
already existed when it comes to listing
off that stuff
um streamers are no longer allowed to
insert burned in video ads all branded
images need to exist on a streamer's
channel page that's crazy that's turning
the witch
yeah that's burning yeah
so uh a lot of people are saying that
they're going to leave twitch although
they they backed it up really fast
yeah
wait sorry I'd like to issue a
correction I'm sorry
um chat was saying it's not three
percent of the height and what it's the
three percent of the 1920 by 1080. so
this is actually a more accurate
representation of that that's not three
percent what are you talking about I
just divided uh 1920 by 1080 dude what
do you this is like nine percent I don't
know man I'm I'm doing the math wrong
I'm not good at math guys right but you
either you know this isn't three percent
right
I did 1920 by 1080.
this is like 100 into the screen oh I
[__] it up I did 30 oh [__] I'm not
good at math guys
correct common cam L dude hold on no
I'll do the real mad and not an l
hold on one sec let me do the real man
let the chat get in your head bro I know
I didn't want to [__] get up
fantastic job not today Donald
yeah twitch is really dropping the ball
though they really just suck man I don't
know what the [__] going on over there
uh yeah so they backed it up so
everyone's angry but whatever can you
just maybe take a look at um otk's uh
statement wait twitch is saying they'll
charge you 25 for canceling your Twitch
affiliate agreement
how how are you gonna charge me yeah
find me why do you need 25 dollars
what the [__] is going on over there
if you are we also if they turn a minute
terminate it we've decided to drop your
contract 25 please what a maintenance
they sound like Comcast a maintenance
feel reducted from your remaining
balance their Manning fee will be less
of the accrued programs 25 why do you
need 25 [__] dollars what is your
financial situation where a couple
hundred a couple thousand dollars is
gonna [__] make a difference in your
bottom line that's awesome
that is so petty and [__] and just oh
yes
it's killing me
[Laughter]
oh so the otk uh letter
what is this well they they were very
upset and so they issued the statement
um just start reading it let me know
what you think just
every so often we find ourselves
catching unsolicited glimpse of our own
reflection chat gbt wrote this
this blunt collision with reality serves
as a brutal but necessary reminder that
our existence while beautiful at times
[__] stop
okay the website you like did something
that you don't like this isn't a time
for
soliloquies and [__] stop it writing
about the nature of existence
while beautiful at times is temporal I
was I didn't know where you're going
with this but you're right this is wild
this is totally [__] cracking me and
that the decision we made yesteryear
[__] who says yesteryear
I thought they were trolling but if you
read the whole thing they seem mad and
look even if they were trolling I mean
the the replies are like hell yeah you
[__] went off right this is Martin
Luther yeah the Declaration well I mean
this needs to be performed at the Globe
Theater this is some Shakespearean yeah
yeah well I mean if these bigger
streamers didn't say something though
they probably won't have backtrack so no
no it I I have no quibbles with the
substance of what they're saying and
that they're pushing back it's just
purely the execution here like what what
is this all I'm saying is I [__] ride
for us fan that's all I know
um that's all that matters me too uh
so they says we reflect on decisions we
made yesteryear well enough can I get
some dramatic music Zach or some kind of
Shakespearean [__] or maybe some uh
[Music]
what's that song Green sleeve yeah oh
this is nice it's a little more sad than
this
temporal and the decisions we made in
our yesteryear were inevitably catch up
to us despite our very best efforts to
the contrary
today
decisions have cut up quickly
yeah let's dance it I have no I agree
with them but what is this man what is
this like creative writing uh my
favorite part is in the I believe it's
the last paragraph they make this uh
they try and make this analogy or this
metaphor and I just really could not I
want to read this about what they were
trying to go for the backlash you've
received today while seemingly specific
is the result of what now feels like
years of anti-creator policy it's the
chickens coming home to roost or in this
case the frogs
because Pepe frogs
the once you name I think frogs is like
Chatters I don't know I don't understand
the Frog thing or pepper
uh the once unique and admirable vision
of a Creator first platform now feels
like a fading and distant dream
change that much
well
the once unique and admirable vision of
a Creator first platform was it ever
that
you used to I mean was it ever that in
the sense like on YouTube you could like
do anything and still get monetized
well it but then that would because they
said it was unique they listed here
reductions to Creator subscription
Revenue
inconsistent moderation policies yep
that's a problem girls be lying and
attacks on creators abilities to pursue
their own independent revenue streams
have transformed twitch to one of the
least creative friendly Platforms in
social media and have undermined the
very ecosystem that helped twitch become
what it is and unlike in the past these
changes come at a time when the live
stream in landscape has never been more
competitive that's really weird because
he's right in a sense or whoever wrote
this is right in a sense that it is more
competitive than ever and and the
response to that is to make worse
policies yeah no I I again that's the
substance of what's being said in this
letter
pretty pretty spot on but what this says
to me the switch policies and recent uh
years is that they are deeply deeply
deeply financially insecure
they're desperate they're they're
fighting for their lives that's the only
reason they would be doing this and and
by the way how does
I don't see twitch being a huge Revenue
maker you know almost all the money they
make
I don't get it I but I think they're
they're broke they must be broke they're
not broke because they have Amazon
backing them but they but I I would
believe that they're hemorrhaging money
yeah Amazon's backing them but like
they're like a big law it may not be
working
and you see kicking all these dumb ass
new ones they're good they're they're
gonna go the same route even faster
trust me on that
um W that's the only way this makes
sense uh make no mistakes the days of
twitch holding sway over live streamers
are coming to an end
Insurgent platforms are on the rise
short form content has seizure to gen Z
market share For the First Time The Very
creator of the elevator your platform by
building your largest and most
threatening competitors
[Music]
yeah that's a little silly talking about
steak
talking about kick that just made like a
month ago with gambling money if twitch
continues to erode the anatomy and
livelihoods of the millions of streamers
who call their service home
I know there's not a million people
making a living from this maybe at most
five thousand
that's more than that probably millions
of people making their no I don't think
so income from twitch yeah
five thousands a lot
I thought that was lost I was curious
with five thousand dunkard I don't know
if there's any info on that love
on how many people uh their full-time
jobs they think it's 5 000. I items a
little bit too much yeah you think
that's high
now I'm saying it's too much right yeah
yeah yeah he's saying that's too much
they're talking on Twitch only are they
yeah they're not talking about twitch
I'm talking about full-time streamers
so yeah it does sound a little bit high
so that's what I'm saying wait you're my
number or their number five thousand so
I'm sorry you said yeah okay so let's
even be generous and say it's five
thousand that's how I don't understand
how they're making money in the sense
that you have only 5 000 people driving
your whole [__] business that makes
no sense
this is not enough
yeah here's three percent by the way
okay so we crunch the numbers
so it's quite it is quite small it's a
little a little bit bigger
but it's still very very small
stupid needlessly small you know
that's just for the logo though
I think if you're doing yeah
I gotta say
that looked like a fairly appropriate
size for uh
I regulate it it's done I mean it's dumb
yeah I don't know why it matters that's
too small in my opinion I would make it
maybe it's slightly bigger give it give
it you know you know what would be
perfect
you know that is everything it takes
that five percent a lot of streamer has
like a a like an animated thing where it
gets swapped out so it promotes like
every of their kind of organizations
brand uh deals if that makes sense five
percent more trust like a little screen
that swaps out and it needs to be bigger
than that usually to be able to see the
ads the ads and the policy and stuff
that goes on Twitch is definitely Wild
West compared to what I'm used to on
YouTube like people are out there like
you said love like just ads sponsors on
the screen all the [__] time uh it's
pretty gnarly it's like NASCAR I mean
yeah
so it is a lot but um
just last week otk concluded our new
show elevated
uh in partnership with Allied and
Progressive
on June 10th otk will host our Sega
annual games Expo these shows as well as
other community favorites cannot exist
under the suffocating canopy
of these new branded guidelines
small streamers who rely on their okay
they always go oh it's about the small
streamer whatever
small streamers who rely on their once a
month hello fresh sponsorship cannot pay
their bills under these new guidelines
and the aspiring Creator who has yet to
press the go live button cannot do so in
confidence
simply put
the new branded guidelines in the
philosophy behind them needed to change
but to Rolling this is the good part
yeah but rolling back policy is not the
intention of this letter
like the car window you pass by on your
way to work
see that's already starting off rough
yeah that doesn't spark me anything read
the second half of them like the car
window you pass by on your way to work
we simply ask that you pause and reflect
that makes no fun that is so bad
it was driving me nuts yesterday I read
it like five times and I was discussing
with Cam and Ian I was trying to like
interpret the only thing okay what I
came up with I know what they mean you
say what you think they mean so
sometimes when you're I would think like
when I'm going to school or something
you walk by you see a car you want to
check how you look in the reflection of
the window right so yeah I was picturing
like you're stuck in traffic and you
look at the car next to you and you see
a glimpse of yourself in the reflection
of I've never done neighboring car and
then it like all of a sudden you kind of
have like a
like a
introspective Montage happened to you or
you're reflecting on your life up to
that point and how did I get here
yeah it only works I feel like in the
situation of people who are like 12 to
17.
well that probably is there
like the car window you pass on your way
to work
oh but they said way to work so they're
excluding the kids right on your way to
work yeah because I mean I drive to work
I think most people drive to work
and the other thing is like the way it's
structured like the car window that you
pass by on your way to work we simply
ask that you reflect
on like the windows the one reflecting
which obviously makes no [__] sense
right like that like you're trying to
come up with another way to say um
mirror they're like what's a poetic way
like the window not poetic
real quick
which again
agree with this letter I just want to
make make it clear I'm not criticizing
their uh their overall message here but
um
yeah I mean was this just chat GPT and
they just like write an eloquent letter
and this was the dog [__] they're like
they're like let me put this part in
let's go like the car window you pass by
on your way to work Dan can I get
Alfredo cam real quick oh awesome
absolutely hey there he is they make it
sound like there's one specific car
window that we all know right
you guys all know that one car window we
all pass by on work well we ask you to
pause and reflect you didn't finish the
the metaphor right or the analogy
whatever the [__]
have you ever knelt down at a fresh
spring
as the snow
gently melts and a waterfall
filling it from all the throughout from
the year before
have you ever knelt over in the end
you're gonna have to break some
comprehend
have you ever knelt over to get a sip of
the fresh spring water only to catch
yourself gazing back
[Music]
reflecting deeply is that really me
that who I am
we asked
we ask you to do like that and pause and
reflect in the spring water
have you ever
have you ever gotten on the scale naked
in the morning
and saw your tiny penis reflected back
at you
on the scales the glass the glass from
the scale
we ask you to pause and reflect like
your tiny penis on the scale
uh refl they continue reflect on your
Origins as a platform reflect on your
current position now you go there and
most of all reflect upon the role that
Creator I I don't care whatever and also
in their effort to sound very eloquent
at the end here
um did they
intentionally sort of pull their punch
because they straight up say the
intention of this is not to ask you to
roll back the policy no they're texting
you to reflect
it's a little just reflect kind of kind
of weak it is kind of weak it's a little
weak because on Twitch they were like
we're gonna leave if you don't we're
going to war and they're like we're not
actually asking you to do anything just
reflect other than reflect in a car
window
on your way I don't think that was
actually their intent I think just they
got a little lost in the uh
fluffy language and
can you have chat GB team right
nah whatever yeah okay so love sent me
an example of a burned in ad okay let's
take a look was this on this was on this
um well valran streams their stuff on
Twitch so I think it was original okay
so this is what looks like a Red Bull
commercial
you skipped it I just went back a tiny
bit yeah you so I can see how it goes
yeah
[Music]
Red Bull gives you wings that's
definitely a burned in ad oh yeah a lot
pretty much all Esports kind of uh
tournaments it does that kind of stuff I
mean maybe not a lot on YouTube here it
is do they make an exception for
competitive events because it's so
integral to pretty much all sports is
having sponsors like that
maybe there's a carve out in the in the
terms of service for that kind of thing
probably not I would sure well who knows
but I think YouTube probably does
because you think about all this live
events on there that have yeah ads like
that I don't know I mean I said also a
lot wigs uh chess chess tournament for
example had burned in stuff I tried to
find some I didn't but yeah I see that a
lot on Twitch specifically
well clearly the announcement was
insanely broad yeah and not explained
enough is this a real comment thank you
for your reflection or is that a Cameron
special
who sent this he didn't drop that no
that's true that's real
thank you for the reflection I think it
really good well they did it
they reflected so hard so yeah they
actually put out another statement just
about an hour ago which uh that was a
screenshot of so that's probably not
even the doc because it happened after
we went live today
oh so what does that one say yeah could
somebody drop their uh their their
latest statement this not this one no
that is the latest one so I'll read this
yesterday I think there's more to the
thread but yeah it's fine
well yesterday we released a new brand
of content guidelines that impacted your
ability to work with sponsors to
increase your income and streaming these
guys ended up bad for you and bad for
twitch what the [__]
removing them immediately so they back
down I mean but why they go
yeah these are bad for you and twitch
really
you just really well I guess they're
acknowledging that it's like if
everybody [__] quits the platform
because of our stupid policy then
then that's bad for us too right the
sponsorships are critical to streamers
growth and build your earned income we
will not prevent your ability to enter
into direct relationship with sponsors
you'll continue to own and control Your
sponsorship business we want to work
with our community create the best
experience on Twitch and to do that we
need to be clear about what we're doing
and why we're doing it okay whatever
so all's will that ends well got nothing
to do with me
we're on YouTube baby yeah
I love you too at our own set of
problems it's true but at the end of the
day YouTube is the best it is
uh I know we've passed this but just a
side note Roman Atwood
I mean
he has an old video where he does
blackface and pretends to be a rapper
called little chimp ew whoa
little chimp yeah
can you drop that in you have a video or
something I mean probably shouldn't play
it but I want to watch it
I want to watch I bet there's a lot of
weird takes on Romana twins podcast if
because if you deep if you make a deep
dive in it
because I've watched a little bit and
I've seen Saucy stuff just from what
I've seen if you if you go back and look
at his pranks in the hood they are very
racist the premise the whole thing is
super super racist and all the comments
are super super racist
um
all right I'm gonna open this I'm gonna
watch it yeah man music video night
see what's on
dirty baby mamas sitting at home trying
to get a seat on this parking cone
little champ records
wow that was so unnecessary
that was wild
I get a seat why don't I could show that
well whatever just him in blackface yeah
I mean we got it yeah you know what it
is
well there it is it's 4 30.
um hopefully I don't have kovid I'll
keep testing so I guess I mean you
probably have to check in with Hassan to
see if tomorrow is happening or not
I just I don't see how I don't get it
that's kind of why I'm thinking I mean
I'm vaccinated and all that [__] so
maybe there's just a chance that I mean
listen it's like anything can happen and
I hope that you don't get it obviously
because it's not a fun experience to get
super sick but uh
we've had we were talking about it
before the show like we've had the most
bizarre incidents with amongst the crew
here of like getting it and not getting
it cam
was living with love that's yeah and we
drove in the same got covered and it was
like coveted positive in like the same
room as love for like weeks at a time
love did not get sick and then the other
one that I always think of is when
hondar came in after his fight with a b
and
he was with all of us he was giving us
hugs like Yo dude he sat next to you for
the entire interview
next day finds out that he's Kobe
positive lets us know the only person
that gets sick is [__] Ian who sits
furthest away in the room from hondar
it's just like the man is just cursed
sorry and but uh as somebody know is
this the point being is just like who
the [__] knows like you it seems like
you probably should get it sitting next
to somebody who's positive for an hour
Hassan's about to travel to Japan that'd
suck for him to get covered yeah I'll
talk to him tonight
Ethan's lawyer who is with all day
yesterday at the Ryan Kavanaugh thing in
the tiny room in a tiny room for like
eight or nine hours let him know this
morning that uh he's positive so
so that's why most of the crew isn't
here if you missed the beginning that's
why we have the council and me and ab
are here but messed up and staying away
from I'm afraid to get the kids sick and
I really don't know what to do about
that because basement time no because
either just came out I can't yeah I know
but yeah that's just not fair
I don't think heel is down for that yeah
[__] my baby but she's like well I
spent the whole I we slept together the
whole night so if you have it I have it
I don't know if I that I don't know the
last time when we all got coveted was
hell dude both the kids Bruce was
newborn and he had a the craziest fever
dude that was
horrible man horrible
the the one tip I think kind of saved me
when I was with Cam was we had all our
windows open all the time it's just like
pretty much Outside Inside yeah that
helps a lot but but when we were driving
together
yeah that's just crazy that's so bizarre
it just it doesn't you know just your
immune system was having a good day that
day or that week apparently was fighting
fight them off yeah yeah who knows well
um
yeah I'm I'm mostly scared about getting
the kids sick and I don't know what to
do about that I don't know if there's
anything to do but I'm really scared
about that that'd just be horrible
Frick man it's all falling apart it's
cursed and we have guests on Friday as
well so that's yeah let's see maybe I
don't have it
maybe you don't have it
but um I am just
when I found out about this the first
thing that goes through my mind is we
have our live show in like two and a
half weeks and
I do not want everybody getting sick
going into the week of that because it's
going to be a very stressful uh busy
time for us as it is the last live show
I was sick as [__] and it was horrible
half the crew was it was horrible yeah
and then our vacation was right after it
and so we went into vacation with like
half the crew super sick and so
I don't want to do that this time so
trying to play it yeah this time it's
the live curse I was sick last live show
too like completely unrelated obviously
I was home right right and now I'm sick
again I'm sick now too like really
really horrible
oh no this is like energetically align
with us dude yeah yeah I agree I don't
uh let's let's you know what I mean
let's keep it let's keep it going let's
keep it strong oh by the way vacation
did we so we decided right we're doing
Bahamas at the end in January during our
break oh right I guess we didn't let the
audience know after much debate and back
and forth and I think I think we found a
way for everybody to go I hope
I think almost everybody is going to be
able to make it yes because we're gonna
when we go on vacation
in the winter
the first week off will be the week of
Christmas and so everybody's gonna go do
Christmas with their families and
everything yeah and then
the week after early January we're gonna
go to the [__] Bahamas yo it's gonna
be awesome yeah it's happening oh yeah
I'm excited that's gonna be awesome
all right guys I gotta go uh thank you
everyone for being here I will announce
on our social medias what's going on
tomorrow and Friday so
uh take a look ether you do for a
booster shot I must be I haven't gotten
the booster shot
or if I did it was a long time ago
but I'll like yeah I don't know actually
R Kelly
um
good night everybody we'll see ya
hopefully
probably not tomorrow just being real I
don't that's probably not gonna happen
because I don't think Hassan wants to
risk it but hopefully we'll see you guys
on Friday
if I'm not positive by Friday I feel
like that's pretty
maybe 30 in the clear right I maybe I
don't want to be the one to say yeah and
then get everyone sick so all right see
you guys
have a good night have a good night